i don't believe that veganism
changed my mood at all i and i used to
tell people that when
you feel better i go nope sure don't
[Music]
bianca i don't even hear the theme music
anymore
we've passed the roof we've done 80 of
these
this is 81 or something 89
89 yeah 89 good year it's still a good
theme song
i got i think i probably a lady might
have touched my penis
89 yeah you were like 11. no i was 16.
i'm sorry i'm sorry to hear i'm sorry
i'm sorry for my loss
um um
okay okay so we live in a crazy time
wild and the
the january 6th was like
where you almost get hit by a car and
you're like yeah it's fine
and the next day you're like i almost
[ __ ]
died yesterday every day that passes
it's like wait a minute
what it's it gets more
serious not every day eventually it's
just gonna stop getting
serious but but the the uh
importance of it and the
the the it's like 9 11 where you just
like i'll watch any footage thing
can you cover that my water no your gum
yeah sorry you had a chewing gum no i
was
i didn't know i was doing a podcast with
the queen of england no i didn't it's
good
sorry guys i chewed gum out and bianca
won't have it
no i'm sorry i just i don't you know sir
your majesty if i had any ideas
just making me clean um
uh so every day it's it's it's
as i'm saying not like 9 11 right in
that
on 9 12 18 18
9 24 i was still watching everything
about it and every interview and every
it's still like that to me it feels very
fresh the reason
it works for me is any woman that has
dated me
we'll know that i'm a ruminator okay
so if we had a talk two days ago
we just had to talk and i and i
go over it and over it and over it and
over it now
if you're dating me it's in hell
well what do you do so in a dating
scenario do you bring it up every day
i well i don't know i think i've told
you this on here but
i had a thing with an ex where i would
say i mean they went both ways i would
go
that was a multiple apology infraction
one apology's not gonna cover it so
i'm gonna need you to come back around
wow
it's pretty intense it's pretty intense
but yeah
it's funny a lot of it were they
laughing
not then but during the relationship
there's a lot of laughs
a lot i'll pause the tv and i'll say
something funny no yeah you'd be like
it's like having your own tv show yeah
um but but i ruminate over i obsess and
i ruminate but
that's how a you write jokes that's how
you do anything
worthwhile as i somebody the other day
was talking about like
you know having a balanced life and i
and i said you know no one
who's done anything important had a
balanced life
like well i don't no it's not
magellan wasn't [ __ ] like yeah i
gotta get home
like you're obsessed and you're right do
the work all the time
um as it pertains to uh
to uh january 6th um
i realized that
this is why i hate conspiracy theories
yes
i [ __ ] hate i've always hated them
yeah i'm on the record is hating them
yes
because i see where they go i know where
they can go i
personally have been on the receiving
end of paranoia
across a multitude of dead like just
from my whole life and it's basically
just paranoia
yeah or misinformation
or whatever and it's it takes a it
[ __ ]
it it has physical repercussions
which i think people kind of think
they're fun it's like no
this is a real these can have real
issues yeah
um which brings me to
i posted it on uh my twitter and i sent
it to you it was a it was a
longie about there's an article about q
anon i believe it's on medium.com but or
just go on my twitter
um and uh it was about
the uh
basically how the how how q
basically what how q anon started yeah
and what it is
and the guy who wrote it and we talked
about the gamer's
perspective right it's this guy writes
uh makes games like role-playing games
and
like the all the categories of gaming
larping and carpeting
got it yeah and um and
q and on is a
it's a role-playing game where they just
keep it very vague
they say things like uh do your own
research
which means
it's what people say like that's not my
job to teach you that right it's like
make
your own way to my yeah yes exactly like
i know but i'm not going to tell you
um and it induces a thing in people
called apophenia which
we all have in mild cases i believe
meaning
we all at a certain point will go like
um it's that thing of like why do i keep
seeing that word
yeah it's a it's a that's bad i bought a
car
now you see that car yes uh but it's
seeing
connections in places where there aren't
the guy gave a really good example which
is he was doing
like a kind of an escape room thing
and he did it in the room he didn't he
didn't really
inspect that well and he
wrote a clue for people uh
and but on the the way the wood just
happened to be
was an arrow pointing at the wall so
then
everyone in the game is like this is the
clue
and you could and he's like and i
couldn't explain to them
i wrote it that's not a clue that just
happened
but so that's all of q a
it's just i it's a it's it's a
self-perpetuating
it's like a flesh it's like a brain
eating it yeah and once you plant that
seed
you can't now dictate like if you really
because the idea is to get to where they
went
you know that's what it was kind of
designed that's like what conspiracy
theories are designed to do
but when they start going to places that
you're like oh well no not that it's
like
no you can't really control it you can't
control that but also you can't control
it
if it's fake the whole like one of the
things is like when people
make some symbol with their eye
that and like it's so if you look on
it'll be like
masonry symbols that yes every yes
oh no one of them was the uh the
basically the horns
yeah i don't know like bush do and it's
all like just their fingers
or they'll be like so yeah it's so we're
caught up
in a mental
a form of mental illness yeah
and they're killing people now
you know it's it's i'm going through
kind of a weird time because i told you
before
that i was always like my
you know dip into conspiracies was
always just like aliens and it's funny
and
astrology that [ __ ] yeah and it was
literally in the spirit of
oh it's a campfire like let's all tell
stories to freak ourselves out
that's that was my relationship with it
yeah not about my life like i remember
my friend
my friend was having really bad uh
crohn's disease because he took this
like
drug that a lot of people take and um
it made him have crohn's cocaine i don't
know
go ahead and say gross thank you
everyone
this is so bad so um we were at this
hospital in the bay
and i remember asking the doctor like is
anything haunted in here you know like
i'm always asking these questions
and he told me a story about how there's
this actually there's one statue it's
like a bust of the guy who
like founded the hospital and they
always face it a certain way because
when it's faced forward
um someone dies immediately so they
always have it off center
and like that [ __ ] and i remember my
friend being like god you always love
like you always ask those questions like
i know i love it
that's that's the form of it yeah you
know i told you
that's why i have why this is why when
people talk about i
like literally get i'm like
instantly furious right but this is the
so then i told you that i accidentally
stumbled upon
an alien convention accidentally i said
it on a few episodes like maybe a month
or two ago
and they were all extraterrestrial i
couldn't believe
that i shared something in common with
these people they this is a long time it
was
before trump but it was all like off the
grid
poor somehow not disabled but like
ill-health yeah white um
out of the at least something's infected
something's like wonky like everybody
had a wonky thing or a wheelchair
or this hair an infection but it just
like they didn't look super healthy
really weird because i was like wait
these are the people
these are my people and they all spent
their lives making
dvds personal uvs which i'm still very
upset i didn't buy to this day because
hilarious but all and they'd have this
these like documents of like mc you know
and i'm like
oh and then in my head i'm like i can't
believe
this this dumb thing that like who the
[ __ ] thinks about this this often is
these people's identity in life
and almost in a like those weird
evangelicals like
if they were like they have to be right
or else their life was like
worth nothing and after i saw that
that's why i'm like this is not that
some people are taking this very
seriously this is not funny campfire
[ __ ] to people
and during trump a lot of my friends who
historically when we were young knew i
like ooh let's get scared let's tell
scary stories you know i heard my you
know my stepmom
is from the philippines and like they'll
tell you all sorts of [ __ ] crazy like
i just like those kind of stories when i
was young
and some of my friends are sending me
[ __ ] and i'm just like oh
no like i've outgrown that kind of thing
that doesn't really
spark the same thing it did in me and
also
like what you're sending me is [ __ ]
crazy insane yeah and i
don't it's weird it's almost like you're
starting to lose
that connection with people you're like
nah dude this is not real like don't
yeah you're sending me this like
that's what's gonna start happening is
confronting people with like it's not
real and then the fact that government
the president trump didn't disavow
and they asked him about it like a year
ago oh yeah no and he's like
it seems like it's good yep and it seems
like i'm
i'm uh i'm i'm i'm like i'm on the right
side or something
but it's so harmful that
politicians we have to agree on what's
real
it's we have to agree and that's the
thing it's like
my prescription for the queuing on
people is
i just hope that they do something
[ __ ] up
that's manageable so that they can
i mean they're it's they're it's
they're 51 it's they're gone but the
problem is that
and that's what i'm realizing because i
it's a long time since i've been in
junior high
yeah and i gave a [ __ ] about these
things yeah and i don't
understand and anything someone says to
me that's like a friend of mine i
research i look i read
you know i don't just dismiss and
everything
a few people have sent me is such hocus
pocus and i'm like
well no no and then they look at me like
oh
yeah like you've changed i'm like you
guys know this is stupid like
who care like ufos i mean what's
happening
terrestrially there's enough happening
here there's enough
to prove yes that we don't need to spend
our entire time like neil armstrong
punch that guy in the face or buzz
aldrin
do you ever see that video somebody went
up to one of the moon landing guys
oh and said it was fake yeah punch them
in the face so
is that what we need to do yes
in times of and you said something like
early on that was so smart
it was just people who wanted to be the
master of something people who
want this
people don't yeah they don't they don't
have you know who doesn't believe in
conspiracy
theories people that have done [ __ ]
people that like bill gates doesn't
believe it he he's the object of a
conspiracy theory
a lot yeah he doesn't do them what he
does is [ __ ]
invent [ __ ] with his amazing brain
that's what he does like so so
it's it's losers [ __ ] losers i want
to understand
why because there's conspiracy things
all over the map like if you
go down a youtube hole where this person
is lizard
okay the internet no this is okay well
my question is
why if you're going to put so much
effort and dedicate part of your life
and identity and something you sign up
for
to consider why not to
the plethora of issues that are real
well somebody made the good point about
q anon
they said uh first of all
they're they're trying to it's about
traffic
kids it's always about trafficking kids
but you know what you could do
what they've done is they [ __ ] up the
existing channels for
traffic kid hotlines because they
flooded them with phone calls
yes yes so they can't they're overloaded
that whoever the
whoever does that is overloaded the fbi
or whomever
um so if you you're not how you're
hurting traffic kids
but while it's that's that's what is so
weird
it's almost like the actual issue
like helping the actuary isn't it is not
their issue it's
knowing that there's an issue out there
because you could easily volunteer
for so many you know there's no game
there's no game there
it's yes you're right they do want it's
about like
being on the inside of something um but
they don't it's like everybody wants to
be a spy yeah they don't want
to help it's like i don't it's like it's
like
any movement there's not that many
people actually helping there's a lot of
people making signs and [ __ ] like that
but
they're not actually helping uh they
the internet has driven people crazy
we cannot i said it last week i'll say
it again
we cannot take this much information
human beings
human beings cannot take this much
information
we are not meant to take this much
information so
i started saying this week that
this is a information overdose this is a
seizure
from an information overdose we cannot
we can't take
false information and real information
actor
politician who's what's who
you're a child molester we're gonna rush
the thing
and then what and then and then
then what were you gonna do like
but they can't we're not supposed to
have this much information
we just aren't we're supposed to get
information from an
elder we're literally they're supposed
to be an el we're built for
like tiny small communities were built
for small retirement communities
and and we're supposed to just have one
elder that we go hey what's that and
they go
it is yeah okay that's what that is
this is not we're not built for this so
and these are and it's and especially
people with feeble brains which a lot of
them have um
so okay i have a question what should i
do
with my friends a few friends that
are there on the other side i don't know
how they i like i can't
relate to this uh this science i don't
i've seen a few articles about it this
week about
how we're supposed to handle cueing on
people and what i've
they're not cute on but they're it's
like conspiracy to where it's just like
dude if you're you're too susceptible
you know what i mean
yeah it's not queuing on but it's like
you're so successful
we talked about a couple weeks ago you
used to have to go somewhere to get the
conspiracy like
the level of there was a barrier to
entry right this was i
was into it when i was like to a [ __ ]
bookstore near the near the
near the mall near the freeway and it
wasn't
weird it's like maybe you have sex you
might get molested
it's always overcast it's never like
sunny
no um uh you're
it you took effort this is just too easy
nothing it just [ __ ] beams into
people's heads
and they can't to the point where
we have an election
one one stack of votes is higher than
the other
and they go nuh uh no it
it's rigged okay you think it's rigged
okay let's go to the court and see what
they say and the court said
no it's not rigged and this is a
republican court
a lot of the time and
they still won't accept it so it's a bit
like
uh people not thinking just saying that
stop sign doesn't mean that
doesn't mean that so you and we're like
not agreeing
it's like if we can't agree on what a
stop sign does
we're [ __ ] yeah and if we can't agree
on
what's reality honestly that's what
the issue is what is reality and i said
this on here but
also i i can't believe trump at some
point didn't say my reality is better
than your reality
yeah like why he wouldn't
say like because that's what he's saying
yeah he's just
it's just a better reality and it
doesn't
so now authority's gone because william
barr said it was [ __ ] too
the the election yeah it's there's no
malfeasance there's no it's not being
there's nothing no chicanery anything
any my old man chicanery
and so uh
we're very [ __ ]
and i don't and my only thing is i hope
that
we might have to lock these people up i
don't i don't see how else you do it if
someone won't agree to what reality is
you
lock them up come on put them in insane
asylums they're insane
okay they're insane and they won't
listen to reason and they have it's like
if a schizophrenic person said
uh that guy's in the fbi and you're like
it's a security guy
and then the president came and said no
this guy's in the fbi
what do you do like the guy's not
actually in the fbi
but if the president says he is he's
pretty credible
and then 150 senators go yeah this guy's
in the fbi
so it's mental illness that's supported
by
politicians milking it for their own
gain but the problem is not
that take all the people the capital
they're just a symptom
they are not the problem the problem
starts
further back when on the internet and
the information we get is not verified
we don't know what's real i mean some
people will use
old videos label them something else
everyone's outraged and it's like no
that's right you guys know this that
that no wait stop everyone
so even at that level people
there's no um standard for
actual information on a small level
about like
just making something go viral yeah that
is innocuous for example yeah
like you sent me the guy being like
you're doing like a black part
in the in the airport that was like
three years ago yeah that's why i was
like oh yeah
i remember this one yeah but they were
showing it like capitalism
yeah are we gonna throw that person in
jail no but are they
how are they doing the same thing that
someone else did
just with a worse outcome yeah like
right well that's that
then you're getting into degrees
for sure but there's a lot of there's a
lot of q and a on orders of magnitude
which republicans somehow
in the past couple weeks have gotten
very confused they're really
at magnitude where one thing
if a migraine is the same as somebody
shooting you in the head yeah it's like
saying i mean the head is still
or or shot in the head is the same you
poked in the face shot in the head
and they go no it's the same thing you
guys did that you guys are in a head
trauma
blm blm and tifa yes it's like
which by the way i looked up right
before we started 93
of those marches were peaceful and the
ones that weren't
uh were
they didn't arrest black people
and no cops died i think one cop dead
during uh a robbery i think
because i had a big argument with
somebody he tried to stop a robbery
yeah yeah um so a cop did die um
but and i don't
it's not right that the cop died whoever
killed him
goodbye right goodbye goodbye you've got
me
um and so whoever killed him goodbye
and uh
so but but also and again
the means the reason they were doing the
march
was because george floyd was murdered by
authoritarian police regimes uh an
authoritarian police regime
and um nobody cared
right i mean until they and it's been
happening for 400 years roughly
and people had lots of time
and they decided to march uh no they
wasn't like
we're gonna imagine if obama had said
anything i mean like we're gonna march
down
to the capitol if obama would be
tried yes he would he would already have
been
he'd already be dead also uh
funny how people stopped making the
comparison if they were black because
it's
so obvious that it's like it's not even
it's not even worth
it's like it's that if it were it's like
yeah
we all know now that's the the only good
thing about
trump's presidency is because growing up
i mean you hear a lot
racism not really an issue anymore it's
better it's this
jimmy carr listener thought racism was
over he's like yeah
the funny thing is a lot of these videos
a lot of the
trouble we've had especially in this
last year boiling over
you notice a lot of these videos aren't
from the south a lot of them are in
places where they're liberals
or where there's michigan ohio well i
mean
trump won ohio by a lot i just mean like
the videos
of um karen's or whatever the [ __ ] a lot
of them are in california
and new york almost no other are in
alabama
yeah or kentucky it's just it's this
place is these places where we
label ourselves one thing but we're full
of [ __ ] so
i i i just wonder about
like it's just not a good comparison
because it's it's the difference is
reality and fantasy
george floyd died people marched
okay donald trump lost you were told
he he was cheated so that you marched
he didn't you weren't cheated he was
it nothing happened like realities
people were queuing on though
so let's just talk about a regular bag
let's just talk about oh regular
the proud boys who else do i have here i
have the whole three percent
the and the the keepers were big ones
they were like the very militarized ones
did you see the video inside yeah they
were inside inside and like the yeah
i wanted to will that's why i was asking
if we should play it because i
brought it it brought up a lot of
of uh the stuff we talked about yep
which one is it that one
[Music]
before you shut up
so where the [ __ ] are they this is them
i owe war we can't lose the old war
we're better than that
information this is just
information ops all right this is the 10
cruise park
this guy is dumb yes he thought they
were going to break in and take
photos i was like is this it he's not
doing it he's doing it he's like
uh there's the mag
with the horns yelling just yelling
voice over actor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
absolutely i think we're good
so then
uh the we'll go
go go go go go wait to learn go to where
the yeah
the big one was the false comparison
just sorry false comparison too oh yeah
yeah of course
and antifa first of all here's another
thing i want to say how many people you
think are anna antifa
where are you i'd say this to anyone who
brings up anti but how many people
honestly do you think are in antifa
80 and that's high if it would it's not
even like
organized it's nothing it's just a bunch
of guys who live in their cars
and are are like and he are just angry
and are more liberal than conservative
people identify
more with their astrology and believe in
astrology it's like i'm
a [ __ ] gemini i'll kill you there are
way more geminis than antiques
it's not anything it's not anything it's
a it's like
maybe 80 people some people have taken
it and been like
we're antique but it's like it's not
even
remarkable it's not remarkable and blm
none of the who was steve uh buddy of
mine said something about
the someone in blm said something in
chicago and they did
with something about blm is a
uh pretty basic what they're saying is
pretty basic
yeah and they also did the smart thing
by
everyone has their local blm yes yes it
was a local bmw
local chicago blm did something stupid
or [ __ ] up but it's really just like
la like it's
the the q and on people are there's more
i don't know in compared to blm but
they're more organized
and they i in terms of like in
comparison with antifa
they're they they're all in
communication with each other
blm was like we're gonna march there was
never a we're gonna march
marching overtake something we're not
gonna march
there and uh you know we're not gonna
lose with uh we're not gonna win with
weakness there was no vi
there was no talk of violence the thing
is when i was marching
the i was marching to beyonce and you
did you did that one
you did on your own maybe two did you go
ahead it's not important i would have
marched with you yeah
racial equality and inclusion
um i speaking of which someone keeps
hitting up for the whole audio can we
like put a link of that of that
of the kids
no i found it you found it my friend can
you send it to him uh
hit him oh i can't find it anyways okay
whatever um
when we were marching it's hard to
organize a bunch of [ __ ] adults
and some kids it's hard i get it when
you're marching for something
you're always going to have outliers are
people who want to [ __ ] [ __ ] up or
people who want
you know this country this country
doesn't fight wars on its own soil and
especially not in [ __ ] la
so some people do have an itch an urge
to do something a lot of people would
spray paint nazis on like down rodeo and
then someone who organized the march
would be like
don't do that come by spray
paint it black it out like there was
always somewhere i haven't seen any
footage of any of the people
from january 6 saying hey chill out with
that [ __ ] i mean yeah once they were in
the senate floor
they're like that's the very vice
presidency it's like it's too late to
yeah but they weren't even saying don't
they there was anything
they were like you know they were saying
be respectful yeah but it's like well
that's
already too far gone but they the goal
was to march
there was silence a lot of the time
there was kneeling
sitting getting up sitting disrupting
traffic and making
um it was gaining attention that was
really it it was like
the ones i mean the one i went to the
two i went to
i only remember one but i know i was a
two thank you
i prefer to speak with my checkbook
that's actually what you said
you're like i don't know it's hot no it
was covered it wasn't [ __ ] hot i just
didn't want to get [ __ ] coronavirus
sorry i know it didn't no one got it
there
uh that i know neil for not giving it to
any of the
people who are fighting for uh racial
justice um
we see you covered and we honor your
peace
um i just they're just different
one was not a ma it was never a ma i
guess in minneapolis
it was crazier but there was also [ __ ]
like in the out when they have you ever
seen the video that la once
there where they light the cop crown
fire the cop car that was just parked in
the middle
yeah the more you're like wait who's
that that's what i talked about when i
went because it was
an old cop car yeah and someone
came and threw weird liquid in it yeah
yeah like i saw that yeah i was like
there was there was an investigation
it's like do that for this if you can
find black people
killing cops accidentally god bless i
think they were like okay
let's give them something to break so
they don't break other [ __ ]
because why would you put an old cop car
in the middle of their face
it's all the the cops put the cat the
car there
and the cops lit it on fire it's all
you got to use your head bro oh and this
is not talking about videos seriously
there's a video there's very clear
videos where you're like
i don't know if it's exactly who but
it's they just look
the one i saw i was like a young mexican
kid yeah it was just like
fishy where it was like there's it was
fishy it was weird
it was fishy but in a way
i think that the
the little like the bait or the outliers
or i mean i saw
two people with a two by four walking
down the street like that's not good
but the point was to march like you're
saying the point of this man they
weren't mexican and they weren't going
to a job
they weren't too black to white
construction two black too white they
weren't wearing going towards rodeo
okay no i wanted to try to put a
positive
spin on it positive racism with neil
brennan
i call they were laborers
uh so this one was like march
it was organized in terms of bring your
uh what is i think ian has that bring
your racist uh
anyways uh basically the goal was to
storm
that was the goal you know what i mean
the goal of january 6th
was to was to [ __ ] up the capital yeah
he the president wrote will be wild
on twitter like a monster truck rally
will be wild then his son said
uh uh nonsense yeah and then whatever
they all said
by combat now somebody else said where
did he exactly
tell them to do that to which i say you
know when they
indict mobsters and drug dealers they
never have them on tape saying
put the cocaine in baggies and sell it
for fifty dollars
rico they just talk they talk in a code
that's
easily breakable and that most
reasonable reasonable people agree
that's what he meant
what he what do you think he meant one
of the i saw
um like uh some you know where they
i think it was a gang land i don't know
this one of the biggest
like weed like this queen pin of like
the wii game in la
she only got she only got tried
on completely circumstantial evidence
they didn't have one
smoking gun yes and even that one if you
want to give
him the benefit of the doubt uh and say
it's basically hey go down there and
rough them up and then your henchman go
down in there and kill him
and you're like yo i said rough i said
rough him up
like what do you mean i don't know i
just thought the it's like you sent
morons
to a place and then according to ben
sasse one of the congressmen he heard
that
uh that trump watched it with delight
of course i mean of course he did like
no one's like yeah no one wasn't like
wait no donald trump donald trump
enjoyed that
um because there and also the thing
where he said i'll
go with there with you and of course it
wasn't going there with it it's just
like no he's going to ew i hate these
people
yeah he wouldn't [ __ ] he doesn't want
to shake their hands by the way i got a
20-foot pole and
i can't wait to use it um i literally
bought a 20-foot pole on amazon because
i got high ceilings and you gotta
twist the for a pole dancing no you got
to twist the light bulbs out
i'm getting all new lights yeah wow i
look dumb i know but i'm pretty smart
20 foot um so
yeah like the false equivalency is is
insane
did you see that with a false
equivalency when i when they banned him
from twitter
they were just like they're not at
twitter
again go to china you want to see voices
blocked
there they will they'll block your voice
all right
they'll [ __ ] rip your your vocal
cords out and chop your hands off what i
do
and by the way about 70 percent of the
world's like that
so you can't just be talking [ __ ] about
people outside of yeah
go anywhere it's like uh tony rock's
joke about like
black girls in the middle east just like
you'll they'll just chop your head off
you just keep rolling your neck
eventually your neck just your head's
gonna pop off your [ __ ] neck
because they're not gonna play that [ __ ]
no okay the
the um the
i want to ask one of these people and
this applies to
congress as well okay let's say you
break in
okay let's say you get
let's say you don't even kill nancy
pelosi and and mike pence
let's say you just tie him up with your
with your ties
yeah and and you get them to
overturn the election
because of a mob
where are we as a country do you know
what i mean like then what so now
it's just whoever has a mob right
because then you're a third world
country then it's just jungle rules
it truly is jungle rule so like do you
want to live in the jungle
because you see how quickly
things can we didn't get it on uh the
video but there's a point where they
find
a a a document from ted cruz and go
it says uh he's gonna object to the
counting of the ballots
he's a traitor right he's this because
they don't know what it is
that what happens a second later oh no
wait then somebody says no wait
no he's really he's with us right now if
ted cruz had come in in that moment he's
dead
yeah you [ __ ] yeah it's over
so the fact that these guys are willing
to milk these crazy people
for by the way if you can't see it on
video but i'm doing the milking gesture
two-handed congestion um
for their so that they can be a senator
you get to be a senator you're
constantly
uh you're milking cr you don't want to
tell crazy people
that they're not cr that they're crazy
you don't you just so you go no
it's true and then you use their energy
to
get elected but the difference is that
this is a unique situation where
before donald trump i mean the gop has a
lot of issues in terms of their party
and it's super fractured
so now the it's not really about gop
it's about donald trump so the party's
donald trump so you
i mean you if you don't have morals and
you don't want to stand up for what's
right
you have to be with donald trump because
that's what everybody voted for
and that's what all the people behind
you
want you to do they want you to be in
line with him so what choice does
well ted cruz sucks but let's just say
like at a certain point
by the way the al franken quote is um
i like ted cruz more than anyone else
in congress does and i hate ted cruz
that's it
um okay so your
that's mob rule yeah they're held
hostage it's like silent hospital they
are mob
they are mob ruled so one of them has to
just say
i'm not voting with you and they go
we're gonna vote you out
fine fine perks are too good
yeah that's what i'm saying like they're
all [ __ ] lawyers just go be a lawyer
or a lobbyist or something like
that means you know what that means that
means being in congressman or woman is
really nice because rather than living
i mean they're already lying kind of
yeah this is
absolute bald-faced uh
alternate reality [ __ ] it's alternate
reality [ __ ] you're
you're you're encouraging an alternate
reality and
so that you go no i'm in the alternate
reality stop signs aren't stop signs to
me either
they're uh something else they're sick
yeah um and and
and yeah like they can't yeah what
so these people
it's just so it's it's upsetting because
they don't think it ahead at all
seemingly
like what where what country are we if
we're
if you can do that what country are we
because the only reason we are a country
is because we all agree that you do an
election and if you have a problem you
go to a judge and then the judge says
yes or no
and then it's counted by the attorney
general or whatever and then whoever won
won no it's not that anymore okay well
what are the new rules cause i don't
follow you
this is non these are nonsense rules
and if they've got everyone in congress
in a headlock i don't mind a headlock of
like
legislation but they don't want any
specific laws
no they just they just want him to be
president
i think that senators and like house
you know i think congressmen and women
care as long as their term is i think
that's how far they see
not so much how is this going to affect
our democracy how is this going to
affect everything in the bigger picture
because
notice how all the retired senators
republican senators
like 40 have spoken out about against
because there's they don't have anybody
to
to of course and i don't mind what i
would say
some of one of them hopefully will go
you're all
delusional and if you don't want to vote
for me
fine right i'd rather be
be a credible person to myself
at night and live in reality
because where does this reality lead
this reality their their alternate
alternate reality which is very hard to
say from my mind
it's very difficult for me is
it's it's it's just made up from minute
to minute
and it's mob rule so
there's just gonna have to be some kind
of reckoning i don't know like i said a
guy got
said it was a little rough that i said
world war z but but um
i don't mean i just mean if they storm
in the capital you [ __ ] mow them down
you just go
here's reality gunshot wound dead
for believing [ __ ] like the lady the
air force
lady just [ __ ] believed [ __ ]
to death to death she she she
she believed [ __ ] to death cause of
death
belief in [ __ ] is that on her yes it
is on her toe tag
toe tag um so about making fun of that
but
the problem is that okay well what's
even scarier
is that now all the information we're
getting is that
the amount of military police
everybody involved in it that they don't
even know how safe the
inauguration is going to be and i want
to just for the record i think
most minorities are over here being like
i told you so no i agree with you black
people were right i know
racist i know oh that was that that was
yeah that's what black people write
about is about um
i because i hate conspiracies um but
black consciousness it's a tough one i
know wait
more yeah well black conspirators are i
i don't want to say they're more based
in reality
listen black people actually have people
oppressing them whereas white people
it's largely
excuse me imaginary the thing is a
conspiracy doesn't have to be a dirty
word it is a dirty word now you know
it's just like
i don't know more than two people
conspiring to do something illegal
right so the fact that
there's enough there's enough evidence
that
black people are targeted and oppressed
and there's legislation again like
there's enough there that
is it like that far-fetched to say like
no the cops
are right really racist like
they go out of their way to associate
themselves with racism yes
that are in our neighborhood that police
us so it's i mean even here
i was watching someone that it wasn't it
didn't um
they weren't talking about l.a but they
were saying how in a lot of
neighborhoods the cops come here they
police we
spend our tax dollars for police here
but those police generally live outside
yeah so all the police here live in
sioux valley yeah
so they take because there's no black
people there really is
where else would they live so it's the
idaho of los angeles it
is the [ __ ] idaho of los angeles have
you been there
it's it's just like it's it's creepy
it is creepy yeah so um
yeah yeah that black people were right
about um
i wouldn't say that i didn't believe
black people
and by black people i just mean dave
mostly just dave and rob rox roxa
conspiracy
he's not rock's more just like i mean
you were you're
weirdly blown away by
you're blown away by all rocks racist i
love
but he doesn't he i don't they're not
conspiracies
they're what happened to what dave him
talk about like david was just more
it was just more like and you were did
you not believe
i'm not like no we day would never talk
about things that had happened to him it
was just
this is happening i'm suspecting and and
whatever so
um but the problem with the military and
the cops are they're realizing
you can't give
comfort or protection
to white supremacists you can't have a
you can't it's like you can't be a
little pregnant you can't be a little
white supremacist
which is what i think cops military were
doing like well
you know yeah you know i mean i just
don't do it around here right
uh and and now they realize like
oh they'll kill they'll kill us they'll
kill
other white people yes
so now i i don't know if you saw the
fbi's
press conference um
the one where they kind of didn't tell
the whole truth
the one where they said like we need
help like if you have any information oh
yeah yeah i saw them but the guy
was i bought it was like we're coming
for you
yeah and i believed it i believed like
this
some of them uh
seemingly really believe in the rule of
law i think a lot of them do
i think i think you kind of
have to to i think a lot of them have to
for it to maintain its
like status you know especially because
trump has been very hard on the fbi
this like his whole term yeah that i
think they have
so many eyes watching them sometimes
they're like a what is it they're
they're called like the fourth
um like uh there's their fourth branch
yeah because a lot of people don't pay
attention to the fbi and the cia
just like yeah whatever fbi what do they
do like no one really
pays attention to them because trump is
so
like on them i think
i just think they have more to prove
that like we are not
as corrupt as i don't i think that
we looked it up it's like the military's
like 45 percent
racist black and latino oh yeah well
it's a lot
right yeah but it's not it's not over
50. it's not
going to be demographic no yes it could
um between blacks and latinos i mean
it's they're 40
of the population
uh i don't know it's all age it's a lot
of graphs
we're looking at a lot of colorful
again too complicated to read it's like
double-sided [ __ ] dildo
but uh but but they're realizing
basically they were harboring white
supremacists the way
the taliban was harboring al-qaeda
and now you realize like you can't
have that and and but now the
the the the ones that are on the up and
up are like well i don't like black
people
right they're like not i'm not like uh
you know maybe they march for blm i
don't [ __ ] know but
but they're they're realizing
you can't be it's too insidious to be a
little bit that
and these people if you heart it's the
way like most terrorists have a
have a um spousal abuse beef at some
point before or
mass shooters or whatever all have
spousal abuse it's like
this where you if they're willing to be
in a group
about how great white people are
they've lost credibility i know
they've lost all credit and i'm not
saying that group is not the police i'm
saying the group
the group is the promised oath keepers
or the k the client it's probably not
the client the clan's probably not that
popular anymore
um there is a
like i have friends who all posted for
blm
everyone was posting one even
two posted me is like i'm friends with a
black person
uh it's a little weird but that's fine
um
and then i just
out of curiosity i go on to candace
owens ivanka
all these people same people like
every single post i don't usually go on
these people's
instagram but in instagram you could see
what they liked yeah
and who follows them and i just looked
at who me and candace owen have in
common
just do it everybody at home if you are
on if you look at the world kind of from
our side
our point of view go look at someone you
vehemently disagree with like
fundamentally on everything and see who
you have in common
i it shocked me honestly it i shouldn't
have been shocked
but i don't know i'm very uncomfortable
well it's not who you have in common
just go
look under their who they follow
and what what posts they like
because uncommon you're not unless you
follow ivanka and
candace owens no no so if i go to
candace owens
followers it'll show you the top ones
that are your friends
good one yes and i
was my mouth was on the phone it was i
mean it's so naive to think
no one will like that if that they're
friends with you just because i'm black
yeah but it's
so uncomfortable i don't know how to
address it uh
because they're not like racist
i had a conversation with somebody this
week who i a guy i like
who didn't understand the difference
between this and the blm march
what do you do when it's like well like
you're saying you can't be a little
racist
he's just i just realized either he's
dumb or he's malicious
either one i don't want to be friends
with him anymore
i just can't do it like i can't do it
it's like i
either you're you're either too
if you can't comprehend that you're dumb
and if you do and don't care
then you're malicious yeah like then
you're
then you you're not on my moral side and
it turns out
some of these moral these sort of
passive moral decisions
end up getting people killed turns out
again crazy small worlds you can get
killed
uh or you're willing to be in a mob
to kill what they would have done they
would have treated
aoc oh my god iraqis treated
american soldiers i feel like they would
have they would they would have violated
without they would i don't even want to
say what they would have done i know
well we know it would have been
it would have had it started terrible
and it would have ended yes it would
have just been
beyond it would have been so far it
would have been rotten.com
ron r.i.p
um but you know what it was like seeing
those seeing my friends it felt like
in the movie in a zombie movie when
you make it out of like a and your
friend runs up and then you see
something and you realize you just see
they got bit it's like and you both
are like oh my god it's like you're i
have to like i have to [ __ ] shoot you
in the head yeah
you just got bit like it's me and you in
the forest against these people
you how how did this happen
how did this happen and i'm really
having because i don't want to sit there
and be
a [ __ ] racist rambo and go and be
like i know
you i know me why did you like that yeah
and because i don't like that kind of
intolerance but i don't know what
to do what do you do if you're a
liberal i mean that's yes what do you do
if you're a liberal
and you now see
where somebody actually stands on things
or if you're
like or not even liberal
decent decent or i mean to me it's just
like yo
i'm black i'm like a minority i'm black
i'm mexican
like what if you're somebody that has
been on the receiving end of this [ __ ]
and then your friend likes
yeah these people it feels really weird
uh like you know that's directly against
this is the most cinematic america's
been in a while
oh here comes
the [ __ ] cops are in on it so now
cops are turning
on other cops is this better than
parasite
most things the cops are in on it
there's like it's there's a kevin
costner movie where
he's a russian agent and but you don't
know until the end i don't remember what
it was called i'm sure somebody was
the one in uh kosovo no it's like from
89
it's always it was always available at
the video store
that no way out was always available if
you needed it
um but there's just a lot of duplicit
the presidents of the gaga and can he
get the codes
where's the speaker mr sir you need to
leave this room immediately missed him
by 60 seconds just [ __ ] like
it sounded like it honestly it started
sounding like it when they said
he's doing a military parade which they
aren't letting him do but
he's doing a military parade his his
presidency is over at noon
his codes he'll be traveling with two
sets of co he has set a codes biden
set of codes hayes deactivate at noon
biden starts at 1201
like yeah the new stuff that we didn't
need to worry about
yeah why do it's very
very cinematic so much and
and then also decisions
in personal relationships of like
which side are you on
like which side are you on it's
literally a side thing yeah
which side are you on buddy would you
play a little bit in the middle
i feel like in blm you're serious now
this is again
blm was okay now it's like yo make a
decision
yeah are you yeah it's like blm's
it's just when you say it's okay what do
you mean
meaning and when in the summer
people started saying hey you know
reveal yourself donut shop black lives
matter over here
hey i don't want no trouble you know
everyone started saying volunteering
their side but it wasn't a witch hunt at
that point
it was just oh cool these people started
talking about there's an
active conversation happening that a
black person didn't have to start
yeah why people started talking about it
on their own accord
showing whatever whatever you want to
call it
um but now it's really like i need to
know
everybody's it's there's all of there's
a lot of racial moles
now and it's like our remember that game
show the mole by the way how many of you
say i am it was
so [ __ ] good it wasn't that all it
was it was in the it's in the age of
reality
okay really good show
what was the point of the ball ernest
borgnine started some old no it was a
[ __ ] reality show
in the 2000s um somebody it was like
that game mafia where somebody's like
the turn code you have to figure it out
but uh it's like dinner
this is yes but this is all
like are you mega
are you kind of magga because i it's not
cute at all anymore
no it's are you kind of a conspiracy
because
it's not it's less cute than it's ever
been
like it's not it's now it's deadly and
now it's
civilization my friend confronted
somebody we know
and she was like i am
not for either side i'm against
socialism and communism
that's somebody says that somebody said
i somebody i know said i didn't vote in
the last two elections because i
couldn't decide between
trump and hillary and biden and there
there was no difference with them and i
was like
nice knowing you it's nice it's
basically i
can't if you're not going to vote
for civilization it's too serious i'm
like thinking
it's really stressing me i literally
play voicemail it's so hard like i need
to have a funeral for the people
yeah but then are am i okay just to play
devil's advocate am i being
intolerant because now you're making a
choice it's like you're making a choice
of i don't believe in our friendship our
friendship was based on these
assumptions
yeah it turns out the number one
assumption was
you weren't uh mega
that was number one and uh
that's turns out that's not true and
then it's like out here where they go
i'm a libertarian
you're a [ __ ] republican you're not
libertarian um and i'm not saying
we need to root them out and i'm just
saying personally
now that we've all seen consequences
right and people
if you still don't care i gotta let you
go
i gotta let you go that's how i feel and
it feels really counter
intuitive collect your things you gotta
let yourself
yeah here's a [ __ ] cardboard box um
did i ever tell the story of a guy
unsingled out a guy got fired a writer
got fired
and um he
he went he was like just 10 30. we're
over on victory boulevard in the valley
and uh and he goes out to his car
flat tire oh no this is the beginning of
a great movie
comes back in we don't know he's still
there
and my buddy kevin goes not knowing the
guy's there goes
who's the worst writer now
that was how we did it how did you find
out pretty crazy
back in the 90s i think i was uh he was
just like around like
he was right there he was in the shot
um so uh are you still friends with
kevin
kevin copeland yeah the great kevin
kubler that backs he was the stage
manager on all that
um kevin the stage manager and uh
i think him and his partner heath
seaford have a
tv show on disney channel but i don't
watch that stuff but i like those guys a
lot
um he uh he kevin coppola was one of my
favorite book
fake book names uh we were pitching fake
book names at all that
and kevin copeland pitched mice island
the [ __ ] funniest fake book name i've
ever heard
my silent um and
uh
[Laughter]
you get a lot of thoughts here they got
a lot of thoughts blind people were
right oh well the funny thing was
dhs homeland security was too focused on
mexicans and the wall and immigration
and they just
couldn't they don't have the resources
to cover white supremacy the number one
threat in america they're like
you gotta go to number seven whoops um
again it was
it was an in it was just everything they
thought
the browns were doing the whites were
doing they thought the browns were going
to storm and they're going to do
it's like we had the wall but in the
wrong place
we needed a wall from white people in
front of congress
it turns out can you [ __ ] believe
that there's a
[ __ ] whoopsie daisy for you the fact
that there's more what is it there's
more
military at the capitol right now than
in
25 000 people in afghanistan and iran uh
iraq
or um yeah or students [ __ ] yemen
uh yeah there's more and by the way then
they had to sleep in
the halls of congress like they did
during blm
they didn't um oh this is what i thought
all right so
during the when they're inside the the
the
congress one guy yells like freedom
so bad which uh horrible writing
horrible
like that's the level they're at porn
would you have been surprised if
someone's like
oh i'm so [ __ ] like white like
it looks like my dick
i bet you'd like that wouldn't you i
would like that
just bad like first grade
play like make believe the guys yell on
freedom
and the thought occurred to me that
americans
only experience freedom
in an antigua antagonistic sense
they never just like oh yeah it's
freedom freedom to me
is like living in a safe society
locks on my doors outside nature's good
i don't have to worry about my wall like
that's freedom
running through congr i don't want to
run through congress
like that's not freedom to me but the
but
it's all of america's it's just this
thing of like
[ __ ] you freedom and it's not even
any it's not any it's like a catch-all
for
it's just anger frustration
freedom about what freedom
they're not going to come here it's it's
just oppositional it's just
it's the line from i think it's a
it's a james dean or uh uh marlon brando
the what are you what are you
rebelling against what do you got it's
like what are you so angry
about like what do you got like ain't
[ __ ] anything
even the i was thinking about the
beginning of the
the uh the
colonies and them being like
[ __ ] you england and england must've
been like all right you [ __ ] psychos
because that's what they what we the
deal they have that we had with england
was
the same that we have at puerto rico
yeah and no one's met no one feels bad
for we not
they didn't march down to puerto rico
for their [ __ ] freedom
it's just they like they were english
and then they came over here
and they were still english and then
they were like [ __ ] you
i'm not [ __ ] yeah you're english you
yes if you want to be
but it's all of this it's never
just freedom for freedom sakes it's
freedom
against something it's never
actual like peaceful enjoyment it's
freedom is rage
and of course the real estate lady wants
a pardon
um i heard he's gonna pardon a lot of
people tomorrow i
he's pardoned i thought he was gonna
pardon little wayne when we started
recording so
really i said rappers which is so funny
why
i don't know because lil wayne supported
him oh yeah he did and uh
again pardons are not worth it they just
get rid of him
i know you like obama's [ __ ] it i'd
rather nobody gets anything oh
no neil it doesn't work for everybody we
need pardons
uh the justice system is too [ __ ] it's
if you're gonna take away pardons and
you gotta take away a bunch of other
[ __ ]
because i take out a handkerchief and
wipe my head
no it's too it's just it's another ch
obama pardoned so many people that or
it's like
pardons clemency all these things that i
mean a lot of
non i come on man michael flynn be in
jail
then and roger stone and all the people
all these
innocent like they these it's a
trade-off i've made my
i'm trading it off okay i'd rather
malicious white people have to if
if it's not worth trade-off getting
innocent black people out and but also
guilty white people ah dude yeah it is
because it's a it's a [ __ ] up system
so let's it's not it doesn't work
well obviously yeah so
that's just that's just a it's a one-up
get out of free get out of
jail i just it's you have it's he's
abusing it so it's like
you can't we can't have that so what if
he gets real it's just not it's not
worth it
it's not worth it just appeal guys if
you're in jail
and you've been falsely accused do the
thing where do a montage where you
you study law and you see a hole in your
case
and then i thought you liked the
narrative i love narrative but i don't
like
this that's narrative you're free to go
is not cinematic
learning to read learning they're pretty
cinematic yeah
out of nowhere you just get to go it's
not a movie you're just sitting there
and then you're free to go
um she wants a pardon and
i also had the thought that um
the trials for these things are going to
be in terminal because
every lawyer is going to be it's going
to be their moment
and it's going to be like i have
something i want to say and then the
[ __ ] guys when they get sentenced to
be like
i have a speech for me and the [ __ ]
guy with the horns is going to speak
it's not going to be worth it he's going
to yell freedom
and i'm also not
the charges that they're getting they're
not strong enough
they're all like disorderly conduct and
[ __ ] like now
you got anything can we imagine they're
brown for a second
just for a second imagine they're muslim
just for one second
i can't believe
it's like you have attached some you can
attach some
funky [ __ ] and they feel good let's get
funky
though like come on y'all let's get
funky let's get funky the bearded guy
that
desks pelosi
he got a lot he was allowed to await
child on house arrest and then a judge
another judge stepped in and revoked it
but
the house arrest that we're all under
under in coven yeah
so it's the everything is [ __ ]
white supremacy yeah yeah um uh
trayvon had a funny thing on the chat on
the thread which is
uh q anon would fall apart if
like 400 black dudes just came to one of
the rallies i was like no we [ __ ] with
cue too
you'd be like yo dreads chains they'd be
like
cornrows they'd be like i'm seeing some
holes in my logic
goodbye um goodbye uh
oh this is it i it the whole thing
this year has been very hard it's been
like whiplash
on who like i'm like
[ __ ] the police they killed a cop
i'm like i'm just like and then i'm like
we gotta i'm against facial recognition
i'm like no i'm like you know what
get them let's recognize some faces
yeah like it's i have no fixed
principles
it turns out because i i mean i'm
they're fixed but i'm kidding but i'm
saying like
the they're even like the i want my the
encryption
and then i don't want whatsapp looking
at my [ __ ]
and then now yeah then you bashed it
last night yeah
well i it's the you know what um
civilization is about it's a the tension
between
uh freedom and safety the problem is
how you feel i think good job um
you're fine with it because in our
opinion it's for
you i like it when it favors my cause
and i don't like it when it doesn't
oh yes but in our opinion those they're
bad guys and they need to be stopped
you know what i also wanted to say sorry
finish but they
think the exact same thing about blm
they think that they face the
recognition blm storm the capital
yeah well yeah but that's not what
happened i mean that's the thing that's
the same feelings
guys i'm gonna put you on medication
because you're out of your mind yeah
like you're there's not just you we
gotta [ __ ] blow dart these
[ __ ]
because they can't they're they don't
live in reality
what do you do when someone doesn't live
in reality and then
congress people and and multiple
networks encourage it
yeah that's we're gonna find out america
um in the next five years hi welcome to
the next five years
um and uh
yes we're oding on information and
uh this is america it's like when they
the [ __ ] that happens with covid where
it's like we're attacking ourselves the
antibodies
the guy the the people at the capitol
i'm all for storming the capital if a
election is really stolen
right but it wasn't really stolen this
is a
fake it's like what they do with rna
technology with covid where it's like
you get a you put a thing inside the rna
bubble and then you send it to your body
your body thinks it's one thing
that's what's happening but it's
malfunctioning
i wanted to say that and another thing i
wanted to say was remember
uh liberals are cucks and [ __ ] but
conservatives will
actually kill you they will
truly kill you whereas liberals will
do a loud exhale and give you a passive
aggressive look if we don't agree with
what you're saying
and liberals will kill you by the way do
you know what
rank california is in terms of getting
out vaccine out of 50.
bad 49th that makes sense we're right at
the bottom with alabama
and i don't
i don't know well i don't know
apparently
the the um
that's the thing where i blame like
that's on
gavin that's on news like the dude you
can't i
the who you shut down whatever but
taking a pile of things and
putting them in in strategic locations
is like
that's [ __ ] basic management i will
say in his defense apparently the
problem with
operation warp speed is that
a lot of the vaccines that they were
told they have
don't exist outside of paper
there are those things but we have a lot
of
we've only used 29 i don't know for sure
but then the problem is that there's
some
there's not enough for the second dose
in a lot of places where they need it so
if they sent everybody
like it it's just too [ __ ] like they
got the vaccine out but apparently
there's a lot of places where uh
if you get the first dose you won't get
the second dose and they don't know when
you're gonna get the second dose
so i think there's a lot of issues
making it hard to
yeah florida's crushing it it's because
they just took
what they had and got it in people's
arms they didn't do so apparently the
tiered
is not good it's like hey everybody this
age you know just come
sign up and old people like sleep like
it's a [ __ ] concert
sleep in their cars in the morning they
got the thing and then they came back a
few weeks later and got the it's a
vaccination festival
vax fest 2000 uh whatever
[ __ ] year it is um and
uh you watched some documentaries i
understand i did
what'd you watch on doc watch doc
so i watched one that was suggested to
me called a thousand little cuts
and it is about um
this newspaper in uh
it's called it's called rappler i think
in the philippines and it's basically
about dwarves oh yeah
it's about the one woman yeah that she's
like i want to watch that
it so it's funny to watch it last week
because both of them that a thousand
little cuts in collective
were all about how
[ __ ] brittle a democracy is and how
weak governments are against
corruption and how
what i got from it was that it doesn't
matter what [ __ ] religion
it is in that country it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter much
because there's so many examples across
so many countries
and just like corruption is just so
strong it's almost it's a human
condition
and it's nature it's like it's just a
natural way
it's chinatown everything's chinatown so
you have to
fight it in this case it's filipino yeah
little manila but it's you have to fight
it with everything you have so
it shows him shows dude
as like a regional mayor or a governor
or something
popular mob mob boss meaning like
it's just a mob and he goes we're going
to kill drug users
okay yeah and it was like cool great bye
and then
when he became president so she um
was running this this newspaper the
whole time
and it went from him being one and they
know each other and it it's so
scary it's basically it's america with
more machismo and like more karaoke yeah
there's a lot more
shittier roads shittier than shittier
cars but i mean it's it's trump
administration
if they all did karaoke and like there
was
dancing people yeah uh and they sat on
the floor
uh they're it was it's so
with and they all all wore flip-flops
it's so
all of them like that's from the bottom
to the top and they're all
three dollars and they are
all dirty um it's so scary and so
basically a thousand little cuts come
from it comes from a speech she gave
about um democracy and how it doesn't
like crumble quickly it's just little
cuts
and every time you take a piece of it
and after like a thousand little cuts
like
you know and you know it's beautiful
what she says but
it's so scary how
bad like when the corruption gets too
big it really is like a virus
you know and there's nobody to stop it
and that one is
it's scary to see all she did was report
the news and all she did was ask
hard-hitting questions but the weird
thing is and
in the philippines from what i gather
like imagine it america trump america
but there's way more q and on like
a lot more q a literally about q and on
or just not
but just like just people who like drink
hardcore that's what happens in
like the middle east there's it's just
rampant with conspiracies
right because it's just like well you
know it's just yeah it's they can't it's
hard to find the truth so in
um in the philippines it was it's it's
scary
it's like as if the majority was
pro-trump pro the conspiracies pro
everything trump says it's imagine if
most of us thought that yeah so it was
really
scary to see and it and they would ask a
question
then they would sue they would go to
jail it's it's so good but it's
so scary and i watched it right after we
did our episode
and almost everything we said happened
in the philippines so it was like
watching i don't think they could do
exactly what they do
here there but it was like watching
there's like a future
and a look into the future if you don't
you
have to it's a pain in the ass it's a
pain in the ass to vote it's a pain in
the ass to [ __ ] march
democracy it really is pain in the ass
like being in a relationship
um it's it's uh no it's just a [ __ ]
pain in the ass
and you have to agree
what a stop sign is a lot it just comes
down to
we are we all agreeing and if we're
living in different realities it's
they cannot coexist um collective
was is about in romanian collective's
the other documentary
collected was the other documentary and
there was a nightclub called collective
and there was a band playing and they
had pyrotechnics go off
and the nightclub burned and uh
maybe like 30 people died and
let's say 40 people were burned so those
40 people go
to hospitals all throughout romania and
those 40 people all died
or most of them died and so it start it
sparked
an investigation and it also takes place
in like
like the like the more like no [ __ ]
just the facts kind of newspaper like a
hard-hitting journal investigative
uh newspaper that was wondering why they
all died they all died because
they all got bacteria they were all
septic
and they were like okay why and then it
just
is like the the company that makes the
the cleaning solution they dilute it why
did they why do they
dilute it well because the owner is
running a [ __ ]
offshore scheme he charges he buys it
wholesale for this that
so it doesn't kill any of the bacteria
so the bacteria everywhere they died by
these
this kind of bacteria you get in
hospitals that you need a certain type
of
antiseptic form i mean there's like
maggots on these people
and when they tried to figure out why
these people did not die from their
burns but they died from
hospital bacteria that they contracted
just being in there
it's the most it's this saddest
uh deep dive into okay well like the
[ __ ]
antiseptic the cleaner company why did
he
well he pays off everybody in the
hospital system and then it just shows
the corruption and aaron brockovich did
all this amazing
so the corruption you see in collective
and it it's just a glimpse into
the problem is they couldn't even try to
do something even they got a good guy in
that
minister of health a good guy a guy that
like fought for all this was
he couldn't do anything everybody has
paid off every single person has paid
off
so how do you that's that's what a third
world is
it's just every i mean i i've asked
like the african dudes that work for
trevor i'm like
how long is it going to take for africa
to get online like for just to be
western and they were like
it's so corrupt that's what they mean
it's impossible it's impossible and i
think we've discussed it on here
it's also tribal that they can't
you can't get elected to office and not
hire your family
your family will will just they it's
unacceptable and you can't fire
your family you're a piece of [ __ ] right
so which is why in western democracies
up until four years ago you would hire
the best people
i mean that and and uh and then you
wouldn't hire your family
you wouldn't hire anyone you it would
just people hire their family here
there's so much nepotism
in i'm talking about the white house um
okay
obama didn't hire sasha malia jimmy
carter didn't hire billy
uh right but when there were laws after
kennedy
about that that i'm sure i don't know
probably yeah i think
there's like weird laws yeah but they're
they're they're in place for a reason
so um so
that's what again civil like what do you
want
what do you want because this is bad
that's
bad if trump gets elected and then just
hires
some of the people i heard today on
franken's podcast that trump hired or no
one maybe it wasn't frank's podcast
he hired a ghost hunter all right
he want he put a ghost hunter up as
as some sort of judicial nomination
guys never tried a case he was a ghost
hunter
what's the difference between nepotism
and hiring your family and
that's all i think it's the same no no
well hold on
or hiring the people that like
like loyalists loyalists or that gave so
much contributions or
that's why you can't or when there's
lobbyists i mean like
it's better than your family because
it's like dude this guy gave me money
yeah uh yeah your family's not gonna
give me money
um [ __ ] like happy birthday
not it's no it's not cupcakes i'll tell
you that right now so
uh i don't what's the difference is
between a lobby i don't know it's all
corrupt i feel like we just dress our
corruption up
in a nice suit yeah
and at least there it's like we diluted
because my cousin
yeah i remember yeah when we were in dc
at that thing and
oh yeah [ __ ] gotham city yeah exactly
although she was on 60 minutes last
night who's she mariam
bowser oh the mayor um
anyhow emails everybody what about your
two
oh yeah sorry wow you gotta [ __ ]
bro um what's going on with you
part two of tiger did you watch it yet i
haven't gotten into it but i also don't
like watching it one at a time i get
annoyed
that's hbo right it's great yeah it's
great
and i had one so good yeah it's really
good
it's just you know greek tragedy do you
think his exes are hot
uh i have a couple observations
one of them is he is the tiger woods of
horrible sunglasses
really you've never seen him in a good
person every single pair of sunglasses
are horrible really every single one
um yeah like it it's like it's a bit
probably in the documentary can you put
you can't even
yeah just tiger wood sunglasses will
just brought up tiger wood sunglasses
and it's a blood bath
so wait hold on
not one good pair and they're all
probably so expensive
no they're all nike and and oh you don't
oh he's like the
but he doesn't have to put the freestyle
right he wears the free [ __ ] but he
never had a girl
taste i think he was right to cheat on
elon because she never
uh they're so bad they're so
they're all so bad um
what's going on here yeah they're all
incredible
he looks blind he looks
blind he reminds me of an old paul
mooney joke
which is um that they're working to give
to restore stevie's site and uh the
people around him better be careful
because when he sees how they've been
dressing him
they're gonna really fight that's so
funny
so funny this is very funny so there's a
woman
in the documentary a vegas woman
who i dealt with in vegas
in a way i used to go not like i used to
go like i was a regular
there was a point when i was doing the
um the jeremy piven car picture
where they were inviting people to vegas
a lot i'm sure they still do i'm just
not in the circle
uh and they would invite snl people for
like hotel
openings and [ __ ] funny so i was there
one weekend
with i mean
i've i'm sure i told the story where
like i flew there with piven we got on
the plane and
stallone's waiting for us on the plane
wow crazy
and then we get there is he nice
sylvester's alone very nice but also
is like a comic in that he knows what
stories to tell oh good he knows his
good story okay
i'll tell the story i told him on rogue
one time so [ __ ] funny
um we get to the hotel there's bruce
willis
so it's like dinner with bru just all
these and then seth kattan
[Music]
a bunch of other people were there it
was just [ __ ] very fun and funny
me and seth are at some club and this
lady tiffany masters
who's in the documentary was there and
she was like hanging
like kind of hostess we didn't know what
the [ __ ] was happening
so there's a point where uh
two women two like drunk girls in their
20s
seemed like they wanted to sleep with me
i didn't buy it oh yeah i knew
but but then tiffany was talking to me
and then they got like into a spat
what uh just some drawing you're
fighting shoes
i know i won't even neil you're not
setting this story up
trust me dude three girls fought over
you so but meanwhile
tiffany and i weren't a thing and i
don't know who they she's getting
jealous she's like yeah
yeah literally so they start bickering
and they say the girls say to tiffany
they go like what are you like
35 and i
one of the meanest things i've ever said
i go tiffany take the compliment
that's so so [ __ ] funny when you
watch the documentary
know that i said that that's really um
was she mad about that
she didn't hear me oh good and then good
thank god because it's vegas i literally
looked over there and then the women
were gone and i was like yeah next deal
were you annoyed at stephanie no i
didn't think it was just drunk pete it's
it's vegas so it's just like then two
more girls it's just
dumb yeah yeah not like literally two
more girls are gonna no but it's not
hard to get blackjack where you're just
like okay next
next hand and then made two morons
common
no i mean again i would i believe
uh have i ever i don't think i've ever
picked up a chick in vegas has a chick
picked you up
no but i'm never like from like
you he's come to my room like it's just
not
in fact one of the nights i went with
pip and i went to sleep at nine
uh um so what are you gonna do um
look to do it all over again i would
have stayed i would have taken my
sweet nodos and [ __ ] ray and [ __ ]
freedom
at 5 00 am your alarm goes off uh yeah
basically
um the descent and the the dissident
is about it's another jamal khashoggi
movie barely
yeah different one it's yes it's very
good
it's a better one it's better this is a
the filmmaking's better than this one in
the dissident
but the information isn't really better
is it the same
it's the same story i mean you know what
they do have in this one is they have
more
they have the transcript of what
happened to him
what if you had to watch one
because i want to watch it because watch
the dissident
what was the other one called the jamal
khashoggi movie
okay um the squeaker
jamal khashoggi the squeaker emails
it's very good
[Music]
thanks for a great deep dive this is
from my friend lucas who um
is in the music biz and is
very good looking thanks for the great
deep dive discussion on last week's show
about the capital hicks erection
two aspects that uh i haven't really
seen reflecting in the mainstream media
that i love you and miss sia's take on
number one immediate optics aside it
honestly didn't involve a whole lot of
people maybe
20 000 at the rally and what 2 000
involved in the riot itself
that's an infinitesimal slice of 330
million
population do you think there are
millions hundreds of thousands
or some other number of trump supporters
who are actually engaged enough to break
the law put lives on the line
to participate in a wider insurrection
effort
or some kind of civil war uh that's a
and b
given that we spend over a trillion
bucks a year on defense and policing do
you think it's reasonable and not overly
inflammatory
to suggest that anyone attempting to
disrupt the inauguration
attack other capital buildings etc
should just get royally [ __ ] up by
the authorities if they try um or
even just for squawking loudly enough
about it as would certainly have with
any foreign bad actors attempting such a
thing
i mean what the [ __ ] are we spending the
money on uh for exactly
uh that and now we're number two uh it
seems fairly clear to me going all the
way
way back to the blm protest in the
summer and the autonomous zones of
portland that trump's overall plan
was to get his [ __ ] with supporters out
on the streets then have blm
antifa and generally right-minded people
get out there also
uh to combat them then uh you have the
horrible martial law thing
um etc etc
so forth and so forth um
yeah i don't i mean the the to the thing
of it being a small percentage
uh the one of them is called the three
percent
which is because they're called three
percent because they believe that's how
many
colonialists actually fought in 1776
that's how many people they believe
fought in the
revolutionary war apparently it's been
debunked more than three percent
but it doesn't they're willing to do
that
i don't think they're outliers
like i don't think that they are like
antifa where i'm like i don't [ __ ]
know
it was an olympic swimmer it's a hundred
and forty
congress people this is not fringe yeah
they're
all on the same side so and
they're all worried about losing
elections
so if you don't side with trump they're
gonna vote you out
so it's not fringe at all it just isn't
french it's a
major major problem i think there would
be more people if there wasn't
if there was more access to it was
summer it was summer if it was like
less coveted even though they don't not
all of them care about that i think so
none of them care about it
some people really do okay some people
do i mean i can't prove you right right
no i just think there's older people
like if there was just let's just say
this happened in
2019 and it was summer
yeah i think it would i think it would
have been moral or z
so i don't think it's a niche problem at
all and as i said last week i
yes i i hope they this is the
the whiplash i have i hope they
dust off i hope they waterboard them
how about that i hope they water i hope
they put hoods on them
and shuffle them around in cuba
i hope that these people get i hope that
they never see the light of day again
that's my sincere hope for living
sometimes i want to go neal ghost i went
i like to go third world every once in a
while
i like to go i have a little penchant
for the third world
you know i love tyler goodbye you've got
my helen banks lscnr from day one here's
my situation i've been
with my current girlfriend for four
months outside of a specific
issue things are good here's the t when
i met my girlfriend she pitched herself
as someone who had never had sex
and didn't have a lot of partners she
then went on to tell me her number
11 for of men she slept with which isn't
high
but she has told me multiple times she's
not sexual
and never enjoyed having sex she went on
to say she's only been with
people she saw a future with but they
would end up cheating on her because of
lack of sex
this now translates into our current
situation and to be honest i just don't
believe her
here's the wrench after we hooked up the
second time we hung out
she texted me the next day saying she
had herpes
and told me to leave if i was
uncomfortable
we took the steps all clear here and i
gave her the benefit because we were
drunk
after further convo i had uh i
found out recently she was with someone
else during quarantine
and she didn't disclose info to him
either started to lose trust in her
started to
and i have way too much doubt about her
past to really let it go
i do love her but is it enough um
what should i do uh to me something
about her just doesn't add up and i feel
if every single uh boyfriend breaks up
or cheats on you
there's a bigger issue i should be
looking for she was a party girl back in
the day and did a lot of blacking out
and drinking
and uh and i did tell her that if i had
known
i wouldn't have gotten involved help
thanks and play the bing song more yes
cue pink song sorry
yeah that's actually not the right song
we're looking for the we're looking for
the sex one that makes bianca
uncomfortable
uh there you go she hates it
no it's just funny to me because he
plays because will just plays it in
funny times
i disagree with a lot of what most of
what will does yeah i like
it but um okay uh this guy
what's going on dude good girl she's a
liar
she's weird yeah she's gonna you'll be
lucky
she basically already stole your
identity and you don't even know it yet
it's like nah too you're giving your
pass on so many
like why the [ __ ] did you do that yeah
so she
[ __ ] someone else i guess before they
met
i don't it seems what when in quarantine
i don't know four months okay okay okay
yeah i don't know i just she's not
being honest with you and probably not
being honest with yourself which means
that a lot of work yeah a lot of work
dude
and also uh if you see a future with
somebody
and you get blackout drunk to [ __ ]
what how do you what future did in your
blackout you saw a future with him yeah
come on
come on what are you doing what are you
doing you know that one kid that
when you're in elementary school just
lies he takes things and the one that
everyone's a little
weary of i haven't talked about dave
very much this episode but one time i
was
i had this conversation with him i was
like remember the kid who lies and he
goes
dave's like yeah i used to lie all the
time and i go what was when he goes i'd
go like uh
on friday i'd say like i have a dog and
then on monday i'd say he ran away
somebody completed it yeah um
yeah this woman's just a liar this woman
sounds
oily do you know what i mean no not
really actually
i'm going to leave it at that she sounds
oily i'm not going to explain it
yeah he's like those q on people uh i
mean do you do your research
yeah do your own research goodbye uh hi
neil have you ever
oh this is great okay you've got neil
have you ever heard of disorganized
attachment i'm a psychologist and i
completed my dissertation on attachment
theory
i obviously can't form an opinion
without a full assessment
but you sound more like someone with a
disorganized attachment style
this turns into fear avoidant attachment
in adulthood
this is very different from the class of
dismissive avoidant attachment that we
all think of
when we hear avoidant attachment i don't
feel like getting into specifics the
[ __ ] guy
uh i'd say it's a woman that's what
google's for however i can't say that
originally disorganized attachment
was uh believed to be an attachment
style formed in people who had suffered
from extreme emotional abuse
such as being raised in a cage wow
alternately um more recent research
has shown that children of alcoholics
addicts typically end up in
with this attachment style this is due
to the unpredictable nature of their
emotional psychological or even physical
safety in an environment
when an alcoholic or addicted parent um
hopefully this information was helpful
it wasn't
you know i was like well what is it it
wouldn't help i can do you one better
it wasn't helpful what symptoms
i have to look now i have to do my own
research about
disorganized attachment style and
all i ever want to know with these
attachment styles and i i fear i know
the answer which is
can i break it so most of it no
i know that's the [ __ ] up thing
because i
in that case bianca don't tell me about
it
i know i dated someone and i was like
that was weird
and i talked to my therapist about it
he's like he told me a
very specific attachment disorder he had
and i looked it up
i was like by the numbers good goodbye
good thank god
you will it will it people with
attachment
type of issues life sentence for your
partner
yeah so anybody unless they do ayahuasca
yeah no really i mean i need i don't
want to put out an advisory about
ayahuasca but here's what i want to say
about ayahuasca
did it again last weekend and
know this about ayahuasca
[Music]
it is so massive as
a a plant
as an experience it's such a massive
experience
just i want to prepare you for how
mousevit is any listener it's
it is as far as i'm concerned you i'm
you are going to meet a god
you're going to meet a god form so
if you're and what i realized after last
weekend
is how comforting
atheism was in that
it was kind of dependable
not like this spirit isn't dependable
but it's really easy to
process it's just like yes yes yes i
nope
there's nothing i think that's true hey
what's behind that wall nothing
any other questions right and now i
my belief system has been shattered
and it's you know like i said about
ayahuasca as i
said to somebody it's impossible from
what i understand
my conception of reality ayahuasca is
impossible
and yet you drink it and it's
possible you know what's weird when i
was when i did it
at the end of it mine was a real [ __ ]
brain melter but at the end of it
something kind of said plant medicines
are not recreational so weed shrooms
anything and they're really medicine and
we abuse it
and it said don't come back for a while
and that's why sometimes i want to go
back but i'm like
i don't know told me not to come back
yeah specifically was like
don't come back here for a while not
don't come back yourself but i don't i
don't
i didn't doubt your um
intentions i didn't think you were there
for like this she's here to party
no no meaning like i think what it felt
like was that
whatever was talking to me and
communicating with me and the experience
i had
it was like you got what you're supposed
to get you gleaned
what we needed you to get mm-hmm you
don't need to come back
for a hot minute yes that's what i felt
but then you know some people really
need to work on things
yeah i mean it's like that one
documentary the lady was there 65
times yeah one of the shaman i've been
dealing with three
over three thousand so and yeah
so but it's just just know that
i i i don't think i talk about it like
party drug but
no if someone thinks it's a party
drawing please don't do not do
there were a lot there's there was a lot
of euphoria
in some of the times i've done it but
it's mostly
like a
it's about as sometimes it can be as it
can be incredibly unpleasant
and it feels like just getting your
computer rebooted
yeah totally where it's like uh
this isn't great i this is not very
comfortable
no but but but if you have things
to work through yes that you've used
medicine for
or maybe you haven't used medicine
before but it
you find it challenging to be your own
therapist through yeah
and uh like literally ayahuasca will
help you
so it's it may be uncomfortable and
rough and you may see
and feel some things that uh frankly are
the most terrifying things you'll ever
feel yeah and also
physically not like physically
nauseating physically
terrifying physically heartbeating like
but like
it's but you're better off for it it's
like
a horrible journey on a ship
and at the end of it you're like a
better man for it yeah it's at the end
we
it's i mean my ocd is
95 incredible so i believe that my
depression because i haven't taken
zoloft four months yes
before the first time my i used to have
a dip
in the floor and
the dip is gone meaning like the dip has
been paved over dip
just emotionally a state i could get
into that was a dip
how easily could you get there it was
all the time not all the time but a lot
like in the day
do you just have did something trigger a
memory that spun
you down into that ditch or was it just
like nothing's wrong and
no it was something sometimes triggering
but sometimes it was just like
my general mood my general disposition
there was a dip
and after not even a very
pleasant experience the dip has been
sealed over and they got the
the telescope's thing where they do the
yeah that
whatever they want yeah the thing it's
flat now it's officially flat
and it's not gonna be the two yellow
shitty telescopes
they it's i'm positive it's
paved over what if you so are do you
keep going so frequently
because you're scared it's gonna there's
gonna be a crack in it or you just well
yeah at first now i don't think there
will be
i'm so far away from the intrusive
thoughts
there weren't a lot mind you i'm not
like i would never go to therapist
when i go to my therapist i never talk
about my anxiety or my ocd ever
when i told my therapist i owed cd he
was like no you don't
and i'm like oh boo-boo yes i do
and then when i told him and he was sad
for a day because he thought he failed
he's like i can't believe i didn't know
this like if i don't tell you
yeah it's fine but like it it's i'm not
even a bad case and
i don't even remember i'm it's like
doesn't it kind of feel like you're
a different yeah it feels like a reboot
i mean it's not
it in that it's not like a new it's not
brand new it's just like this is better
like it's a little bit like oh this is
better this is like i
i the other last weekend when i did it
it was
one of the themes was like enough with
the grievance
just constant [ __ ] like i'd wake up
in the morning and be like [ __ ] them
like every day i'd wake up and be like
think of a [ __ ]
someone who'd wronged me and that was
all that exhausting
yeah yeah i'm exhausted look at me i'm
exhausted
and since last week and i haven't it's
been
gone the question do you feel
like aurea do you feel like oh cool like
uh
replenished after you do ayahuasca to
that like
nice neil to i have it
the padre he's not dead it's a milder
he moves far milder padre he lives in
huntington
he lives in huntington beach he lives in
are you looking for the padre
change of a dress um so there's a padres
song
what happened
spear padre is
he exists but he's more like he doesn't
have a poncho on he's got like a
decent suit right now right so i'm it's
it's
it's [ __ ] that's very hard to put your
finger on meaning but i'm just saying is
it do you get replenished or do you feel
different is it a different after effect
every time or does it feel so far it's
been a different after effect every time
does it ever like let's say the first
time it kind of helped with your
snappiness does that stay and then
another thing gets
improved or does that kind of fade and
then another thing gets worse
uh with the snappiness it's hard to say
like i think it's just yeah will can
tell you
thank you
you're welcome uh spirit padres is here
uh yeah
like it i the stuff that last that i'm
just more i'm aware of the last time
the last two times the last two times
one of them was
after 10 days i realized that my dip was
sealed over
that's good and it's great and like i
don't think i'm ever going to need
antidepressants again wow that's crazy
like i'm pretty sure
i again i can't be that sure but it it
feels like
granite the dip like that's not like no
that's not even
that's not gonna happen but it's again
you're talking about like uh
good non-dimensional thing and then
this past time uh
she there was like a thing about
heaviness
and sort of a healing yeah again
don't worry don't worry you'll get it
either you you'll get to do it
you get it or it sounds cheap and again
you know what i'm like
so a woman did a healing on me and
i felt 20 pounds lighter emotionally
outside of this five minutes afterwards
i want the healing can you get it
without the
you can't here's the thing about the
healing cannot request it
[ __ ] really that's so weird cannot
request that they have to be inspired
to heal you can i just like go walk like
visit this lady no
no she's not a healer she's a one of the
shamans
oh he goes apprentices there's a part of
the ceremony
where people are uh channeling
and she channeled he uh she
some of them can can heal well and when
i tell you she healed me
i swear to god yeah no it's you yeah so
yeah um so
but you know maybe it's a halo and it'll
fade i don't know there's a show called
the bling empire which is
another trashy reality show but it's all
asian people in l.a i tried watching it
i couldn't get into it it was terrible
no it's not good uh it's interesting
i watched bad reality tv so i could but
after two episodes it was on in the
background while i was doing something
else
but at one point this guy's like i
brought my shaman to the to our bonfire
so this is like the most la [ __ ] so this
black guy
comes and he does
you've showed me what they do and he
goes like
i'm doing like hardcore like karate
shopping
okay so this is what's going on and then
i'm it's a show so who cares i only
thought about it because you told me
yeah there's some handshake going on
when they heal and it sounds
like [ __ ] hocus pocus so i would have
never
even thought to entertain that that
could have been true in the [ __ ]
bling empire on netflix only because you
told me
that someone did something this works
literally they do that he's doing a
blowing with
him like a fist that's like
on your stomach and you're it's like
babies entertaining babies and then you
find a group
you know what i said i said it's like
air guitar but surgery
they're doing they literally do fake
knots not fake knots but they're like
air nuts they do air sutures
it's the and the woman said an angel
came and was incredibly gentle with me
and she's never seen an angel be that
gentle oh that's amazing
i made it only works this information is
only valuable because it's you yeah
that's
because yes yep [ __ ] right i'm
i'm a man that cynics turn to for
strength
cynic padre yeah i'm a cynic padre um
goodbye is it safe to say that every
single person who stormed the building
or even gavin and dc this past tuesday
suffers from some degree of mental
illness
people have argued correctly for a while
the country needs to have a more open
national dialogue about mental health
i'm wondering if you guys think that
this weird moment in history can be used
to illustrate the importance of that
sincerely neil
um sometimes i have to get the message
out i have to write to the show
yes yes um goodbye
neely feely and binky winky i hope you
guys aren't tired of talking about
mental health oh no
whoops i've recently been considering
becoming vegan to help regulate my mood
i have borderline personality disorder
and since cutting out sugar a year ago i
noticed a significant difference
i'm wondering how much do you think
being a vegan has actually improved your
mood
as a side note i totally agree with
everything you've said about therapists
and how frustrating it is to navigate
treatment plans and the mental health
system finding your netflix special and
podcast really opened my eyes to all the
different options i could try
thanks for being a human guinea pig for
us depressed people everywhere
best um i
don't believe that veganism changed my
mood at all
i and i used to tell people that whether
you feel better i go nope
sure don't i don't think it improved my
mood at all yeah
uh yeah but i believe sure it's better
for you
uh yeah of course it's better for you
and if you believe sugar changed your
mood
then yeah you know
you've heard us talk about borderline
it's a [ __ ] hard one
it's not bipolar but but borderlines
explain it for people
it's just borderline is like uh if
a mood was a weather system borderline
people
get weather systems without warning
flash flood flash flood and they
think you hate them and you can't
convince them otherwise
and they they're just they're mood
craters
and it's just like everybody hates me
or they'll stop talking to you because
they think you hate them
or that it's just very mercurial and
uh they're
you know i think i dated someone with
borderline
you know also it's one of the ones it's
one of the mental health disorders you
can't directly tell
the person they can't they're like no oh
because i know someone that was
diagnosed with i know two people that
have been diagnosed
they get diagnosed but i guess the way
you diagnose them
surprise party it's a little
you can't just you have to do it a
certain way like when the therapist
suspects it's borderline
it's like a it's a slow massage so great
um but i did and it was always i was
either [ __ ] [ __ ] or
the queen of the world there was no in
between yeah
i was so exhausted i was like can i just
be chill can we just chill
a buddy of mine used to unfollow me all
the time on twitter and finally i was
like what's happening
wait that's it he'd unfollow me and then
follow me and don't follow me that
some people do and it's like i didn't
know what's going on buddy
and he finally just told me
i'm i'm borderline and it's like
okay and he'll call me sometimes be like
everybody hates me
let me say okay all right goodbye you've
got mayo hey soy boy
and beautiful binky i'm calling in
because probably every other episode
neil mentions that um
people who have babies are
in irresponsible environments real quick
thank you for reminding me
if you have babies you're a climate
denier go ahead you're a climate change
denier
and also you're if you have babies
you're as good as an uh
anti-massacre and [ __ ] it anti-vaxxer
okay
go ahead and it's the worst thing for
the environment
which um it's probably true but i'm
calling because i'm wondering what neil
thinks we should do about this does he
think that we should
stop having babies all together and then
just end humanity
um or does he want more of a selective
process
thanks guys yeah neil what the [ __ ]
lottery thank you for asking lottery
system
we figure out the the amount of people
we can have that we can
that the earth can sustain by the way
there was a stat a few weeks ago that
there's
now more [ __ ] on earth that
that's human made by human beings then
it weighs more than the earth
disgusting yes it weighs more than the
ocean
and the mountains it's so
gross um and
yeah we just figure out what's the
what's the right amount of people that's
sustainable and then you just do a
lottery
and you can sell your slot i would sell
my slot yeah but
but i looked it up after one
one of the times you said it and the
number one i got a compost bin out back
by the way i added it this week
go ahead i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
bulletproof i know
but uh you know
obviously having more people is not good
but there are
one we all have sex which is how you
make people so no one's saying
stop having sex i'm not saying sometimes
i know no no i know
i know i know i'm saying no one's saying
stop having
i'm just saying it is it doesn't like of
all the things to take aim at
i feel like having kids is the lowest
because that's one thing
i feel like is going to be the hardest
to change but there's so much other [ __ ]
that we do
oh yeah i don't think that i think that
there's like the number one things in
front of it
combustible like is just like
is just the the cars yeah emissions
fossil fuels everything like that that's
number one and then when you break it
down it's like
you fly a lot that's not good not
anymore
okay no one's flying anymore i'm just
saying before like you'd gone
okay
we do things that i just feel a little
bit like
i buy carbon offsets for flying what do
you do
you can buy they'll plant an amount of
trees to offset
how much [ __ ] you spew no i understand
but
you know in the end this spewing happens
instantly whereas like what a tree
eventually is going to happen
uh so i'm just saying that got you uh
squeaky uh so there's just a lot more
things we can do and take aim at
before it's let's not have kids well
no but people aren't doing that either
oh i know
but what i'm saying is it's so much
it just makes more sense to me to
i guess the messaging be things people
can
totally do yes then
that i think you're just being like
partly being funny but sometimes you
don't sound like you're being funny
so it's like well okay sometimes you're
the environment not being funny deadly
serious
some things are not people ask me some
things you won't joke about
and i tell them i'd say have a seat and
the environment's wonderful thanks for
coming okay um i don't think we've met
i'm neil
uh yeah i of course i made money but
people won't even
eat less meat like people won't do
anything so i'm just goading them
goodbye cool carbon offsets locomotion
instant trees instant trees you've got
males
the guy from uh i was recently at the
dentist for
filling and when the guy started
drilling on my tooth immediately went
into a rant about q
anon and pizzagate saying that
celebrities are pedophiles if you see
pizza symbols it's a sign for a
pedophile ring
crazy [ __ ] like that is this just a sign
that i need a new dentist
or is this what i got to expect with
people in 2021 how
you feeling well thank you thank you
i mean i guess there's like just a
certain amount of dumb [ __ ]
is there a certain amount of dumb [ __ ]
that everyone's gonna believe
you know what i mean because because if
you look at like
it's queuing on now and they were like
in one of the articles they said we
wonder why so many evangelical people
believe
ah you can't figure that out um
the fake story thing nothing um
so i think there's a permissible amount
of dumb [ __ ]
and then at a certain point it's just
this is too
this is too much i like that um it was
on the internet i think you also posted
it but i did see it on
like i don't know twitter read it the
triangle of
uh the amount of conspiracy theories
it's like okay like that's fine
oh yeah that's the hierarchy the
hierarchy and then it just gets like
and i remember when i looked i'm like
yes not
bad good pretty good um but the amount
of people i know
that get higher and higher up and not
all these people i know are my close
friends i mean
there's plenty of people work in comedy
that
it's like what yeah in entertainment
that you're [ __ ] confused about
because
you share common bonds and you can have
a good conversation with russo
i guess ask his question again do you
think there's going to be more
do you think it's become more
commonplace to
like just talk about really [ __ ]
weird conspiracies
aloud and not in the corners of the
internet i don't know
i think people are gonna get there's
gonna be fights
in public i honestly
if people are drinking i'm it'll be hard
for me not to
it'll be hard for me not to scream at
people yeah and i'm a spirit padre
like it'll be hard
[Music]
some of these people i'm friends with
john and chrissy
yeah you know what i mean like you're
talking about people that i
know like what they're doing to chrissy
is so
mean shut the [ __ ] like to like that's
one of those things where
i i don't it's i've talked about it
before when dave
went to africa there was a thing about
how much bill cosby appeared on his
television and just like
she you're so [ __ ] dumb stop it
well i don't think no i'm in it i know
i'm
in it so don't tell me what's happening
uh i think this guy's either
i think this guy has got to turn to
self-dentistry to his own teeth
okay i think he quit your dentist i
don't know what's gonna happen i hope it
doesn't get worse but
but nothing ever doesn't get worse right
so but i haven't heard 5g or bill gates
in six months so that's good goodbye
big ring banks big rig banks an
ayahuasca flock of flame
of force but we'll accept it in an
episode a few months ago you two talked
about using shame as a way to change
people's behavior
i'm obviously paraphrasing here but neil
mentioned that [ __ ] shaming and fat
shaming could
be effective in some ways it wasn't
mean-spirited but i think neil was
basically saying that
making someone feel bad about their
destructive behavior was at least one
option
when trying to get them to be more
careful or take control of a vice
more recently uncle neil talked about
liberals belittling republicans
and having no interest in even
considering their point of view which is
not an effective way to change someone's
mind
and i think that's true on policy and
morality stuff but here's my question
if shaming can work on [ __ ] and fatties
hopefully from mark norman you're right
isn't it reasonable to ramp up the
shaming of
[ __ ] idiots who deny facts like the
election results climate change
covenanting etc
the only problem with that though is
that people being shamed can use bad
faith arguments like
you're just treating me like i'm stupid
because i'm a republican to wrap this
long [ __ ] up
let me just say i'm not pulling the
cornball move of trying to make you
sound like a hypocrite or whatever i
genuinely think you have drawn some
intellectual lines between the
effectiveness of shame and flatly
telling someone
their arguments aren't based in reality
and i'm curious how that looks
um i don't
and what does binkasaurus think of
source it's
good bianca loves this that's the fun
part that's the playground to be honest
uh i don't know i don't know how to
there was articles about how to handle
these the q and on people
i don't under i don't let's just not say
q on let's just say the people
who were like one step before conspiracy
theory just
anything more towards that are not
reality-based that are not reality-based
um
how do you i i've seen things like you
can't yell at them you can't shame them
you can't
i don't know what to say
if somebody i can walk away if i don't
if i'm not
close with them if i'm close to them
i think at a certain point you have to
go look man
i don't agree with you
and it's or it's not even a matter of
agreement it's that's not my reality
and the reality i live in is
what was known as reality until 2012.
um so um
like i can't i can't play that
game with you so i we can't be friends
anymore
and you're an ultimatum i don't know
what i can't live a life
where someone i care about is believes
this
so it's just it's like it's
so confusing because i
i feel like it's almost a world first
where you have to convince people of
what
is happening of what isn't happening
well whatever what you have to agree
like what's happening meaning
joe biden they everyone voted oh yeah
that was three 240 million people voted
and
250 i'm sorry 150 million people voted
it's like a reverse
mandela effect and like now so now this
happened
and that's what happened because they're
getting
a stream of disinformation and nonsense
but so you just have to go i can't i i
can't it doesn't exist
in my reality and i hope
i you don't even have to put like i pray
for you any of that [ __ ] you just go
i it's not my reality and that's the end
of the relationship
you know what i think but again i i but
again i i
no human beings ever had to deal with
this so
uh and the funny thing about kunal and
the fact that it's like
rooted in um it's all about protecting
abused children yeah and then i
read an article actually and then i
heard the daily did a thing on
how um
bad so the the body that
goes after child trafficking on the
internet and
child porn and pornographic stuff it's
so overwhelmed in the last
like apparently there's so much more
child pornography and child abuse and
child
sex trafficking now than ever before
that uh and they're so overwhelmed that
they
only so this is kind of sad and
disgusting but they can only
prioritize the worst uh under
like two or under one
because that's how little people stay in
that department because it's just so
obvious
it's unbearable and they have to
prioritize infants
they can't even toddler like you're out
an infant they have to prioritize
and that's even just like in l.a i think
they don't they can't even go
and pursue other forms of abuse because
there's so much
so to me q anon like if you're really
about saving
why is the problem getting worse i mean
like it's so easy to
dispel a friend of mine who is like
i don't know what's going on with her is
all this like save the children [ __ ] on
her
social media and i'm like you're what do
you this is not
helpful yeah they're jamming the system
with nonsense
it's already god it's already bad and
then they're jamming it with
making they're just making it worse it's
just
disgusting think about it just go pick
up trash
like if to [ __ ] help the world go
rake the park
break the park pick up trash
soup kitchen just there's things you can
do that
aren't that are that are actual that can
help people
today it's so depressing i'm starting to
get a dip
poof seal over i got just some juice
right over that thing goodbye
you've got mayo hola nardo and big
buckinster hi miss nardo um neil i agree
that we should all live with eyes open
to the environmental consequence of our
lifestyle and it's great that you're
non-procreating carbon offsetting vegan
but i don't think that the mask analogy
fits
we're all connected to a vast social and
economic engine that
that's doing great damage to the planet
when it comes to climate change
almost none of us uh are really wearing
a mask except for buddhist monks
and those people who bought tickets to
the cruise ship that bill bird
torpedoed that's a that's a crossover
episode right there
anyone living a first world lifestyle is
complicit in the damage and although
your choices are admirable and worth
emulating don't kid yourself
in a chin scout it's a chin strap mask
at best and your elegant schnoz is
still hanging out look i love a good
[ __ ] that was in the back of my face
uh yeah but pal
people aren't doing as much as me and
they oughta and if everyone did it would
end the meat industry it's just
there it's all a lot of the
ecosystem [ __ ] of just like ah what am i
going to do
amazon sent me a box which i am a major
part of
yeah would be just do what you could do
more than you
are doing that's all i'm saying like
like i've asked
i've said to people like rich dudes like
hey you want to drive
my tesla you want to test drive it no
i don't even want to i need the i need
the engine
i need to hear pistons
cool but i mean when i looked into it a
huge
a huge issue in climate change a huge
factor is
electricity that comes from our grid
from coal yeah
but it doesn't a lot of it's
hydroelectric solar there's other there
are others i just mean that like
everyone is contributing so why don't we
just go to the biggest factor we can
actually
target and concentrate on fossil fuels
yeah
that's it i'm not but electricity is
gonna
take their place then you have to go
uh i don't want then get my electricity
from not
coal right there you just you go okay
and they go
uh problems here now you go all right
let's fix that problem
goodbye you've got mail
oh this is kind of good i think um yeah
neil and binks i just had a fight with
my girlfriend about arnold
schwarzenegger been there
she was watching a video of arnold
denouncing the storming of the capital
with
swelling violin music in the background
granted he was saying good stuff but
when he
he whipped out the conan sword i laughed
my girlfriend in tears from arnold's
speech was disgusted at my laughter and
accused me of being cynical
and it blew up into a fight i think she
thought that because i was laughing at
arnold i was also invalidating her
feelings in a roundabout way
uh if she usually women don't do that i
don't know how that's happened
this one got away from us if she thinks
what he's saying is great and i laugh at
it then
i'm indirectly laughing at her i'm fine
having disagreements in a relationship
obviously there are some things like
core values that should be closely
aligned but for the most part i think
disagreement is normal and healthy
h f and what does the aphro le tanks
minx banks thinks
oh my god that was so good best and best
we've ever had
the best we've ever had and you nailed
it neil on the first try with that moist
ass mouth you nailed it not moisture
magic
um uh yeah i uh
well i don't even know what the question
is you know what it was worth
it so the afro le tanks ming spanx
thinks
oh no no here you say there are some
things like core values that should be
aligned
basically to date i like fighting
yeah you do but how close because if
a girl if you liked her and then she's
like i'm mega
oh yeah then goodbye goodbye how how
much of a fight like
what is like fun fights to you like was
this
i like fighting about men and women just
generally
like you and i do i enjoy it i just
think it's i think it's
it's number one issue affecting
a couple okay our gender differences and
uh but like politics
yeah you don't want to be that most
people aren't successful you don't you
got to be
[ __ ] you got to feel pretty much the
same thing i mean you kind of want it to
be
where she's me meaning she's a [ __ ]
soy boy and they
talk [ __ ] about climate change and all
that stuff yeah you're on the same side
you can just debate yeah it's just it's
just it's it's
spectrum issues um so
yeah yeah but how about you uh same i
feel like okay for example me and you i
don't think
this isn't you know the hannity
encounter
it's not existential it's very rarely
what is it crossfire like these aren't i
don't
the the ones where you go in knowing
that guy is the
left and this guy's the right i don't
know how fruitful they end up being
because well they can't say anything
original they don't know
they have to go back here's what i think
and it's like in this band of [ __ ]
yeah so that's not interesting to me and
i wouldn't want to
be sleeping with that because it would
surprise me goodbye you've got man um
hello neil and bianca when talking about
hilaria baldwin scandal neil mentioned
that white people's culture is so
non-existent that they have to steal
from other people's cultures
as a white woman i completely agree with
this take she can't even come with an
original take
um i find myself envious of other
cultures because mine feels so lacking
one time i attended a jewish engagement
party where i was the only gentile
present
it made me envious of the community and
the support my friend had because of her
jewish heritage
obviously i'm not forgetting the
struggles that jewish people have had
had throughout history i'm forgetting it
and i'm talking about their culture
and support bianca what aspects of your
mixed heritage do you embrace the most
neil do you embrace anything besides
your irish catholic guilt yeah neil
whatever i look forward to hearing your
thoughts
love the podcast uh what do you embrace
um really uh family
that the family aspect education is that
especially do you think that's
i mean what do you consider yourself and
where do you get that
um both sides really family
i feel like that's just most people are
family oriented right but even compared
to
americans it's just it's like a
different it's like an extra closeness
that you get with immigrant people
italians would like it would
like to speak with you okay
so family what's caribbean iranian
africa just the
i don't know how to explain it but it's
more
this the sense of community getting
together i'm always the one that like
gathers people even with my friends so
well i'm kind of the gatherer
um you just
like a steady like hey
let's do this on sunday let's do this on
saturday come i'll make food and
check in and you know i don't take much
time in between i'm
always just family-wise
feeling like i don't know like uh
just this i feel like there's more
keeping up appearances
within immigrant families uh meaning
i see it in other it's just it's not
just mine so i just noticed like you
just
whether you want to go or not you go
well you can find that you're going to
hurt mom
no no oh mama wants you you want to go
you want to go like you want to go it's
not like you're getting a good thing
just the hanging out with just
fam like a lot of family time a lot of
sitting
no agenda no plan sitting with your
family
talking a lot yeah no
end time no okay yeah
time to go kick in it hardcore all the
time
like like nothing nonsense just kicking
it so that
i feel like i don't see that as much
just aimless kicking it
with all your family i don't know maybe
i'm making that up but also last time
that we had a brennan family reunion
yeah you guys call it a family reunion
yeah like lead because because
why are you reuniting we disunited
because we kept our distance like it's
so rare with white people they make
shirts
you're a [ __ ]
you're a filthy iranian [ __ ] um
it was so it me and kevin my brother
sponsored it and
anyhow he ended up punching me in the
face on day four
and then another sister told one of the
other sisters that she's a bad mom
it broke down pretty quickly and that
was uh so good you heard the movie about
2000
that was in the year 2000 in the year
[Music]
actually it was 2002
it was 202 because i had a videotape of
a pilot i'd worked on with dave
chappelle
i need you to can you write this into
something funny
it's not it's a tragedy it's not funny
at all
it wasn't wacky it was painful oh and
pretty gross goodbye you've got
mayonnaise
happy new year i have a quick i have a
quick question i was wondering if you
have any recommendations for books about
the history of stand-up and comedy
general uh no just go on
google and while you're there look up
disorganized
attachment we need to know you don't
mind
just go on uh i'm reading one right now
at seinfeld's
recommendation called the comedians
which is about
the best about the comedians of the 50s
who were the first
generation of comics to uh
write stand up from their point of view
and not just like my wives
take my wife please uh
mort saul etc nichols and may great
great great artist
goodbye you've got mail hey neil
hey nyophile and b anka the thunka
lscner well that's nice uh this week you
mentioned
your dis taste for people mouthing your
words i myself used to get called out
for this throughout my school years
i it has since passed thankfully r.i.p
queen um it was
it wasn't until a few years ago however
while speaking with a fellow adhd
diagnosed person that they do it too
turns out their doctor mentioned it's
not an uncommon trait amongst
those with neurodivergent diagnoses
i have a neurodivergence where i can't
say neurodivergent
diagnosis i.e autism spectrum adhd
stems from our tendency toward hyper
focus and hyper fixation
as beyonce bianca mentioned it does
coincide with trying to pay more
attention to things that are interesting
i would say it's a form of active
listening okay
um i by the way that brings up the thing
i don't want people to call themselves
feelers i want them to call themselves
active listeners because it's funnier to
me i like feelers
i think okay well both yeah let us know
which one do you guys
let them vote with their sign-offs let
them vote with
yeah i'm an active listener okay uh you
know
where your bread is buttered and you
know that i will venmo people
for helping me win
i hate to be the one to tell you this
neil i love how every
every letter is it like neil hey yeah
but hey you sit out
but it may be it may even be considered
somewhat insensitive to call out say
it's annoying or telling people
to cut that [ __ ] out although i can't
speak for those that mouth what you're
saying personally i think it's just a
hilarious
and more of a general quirkiness who
knows and maybe this is an evolutionary
theory
but what if it's an evolution of the
brain and anticipating social behaviors
of others
yeah what it is your thoughts what if uh
that'll be wild another thing
to that we can't talk about that's so
insensitive it's so wild and
those people are hurting these people
are throwing themselves off bridges
because of me telling them to knock it
off anyhow
goodbye you've got mail bianca neil so i
watched the accusation
uh i'm like 95 percent sure she's
telling the truth that's this is the
movie about
yeah the the head of the world bank imf
imf
uh i'm like 95 sure the cleaning lady is
telling the truth
and i have a question you both hang out
with the rich and famous me not so much
but i'm aware that if you have
such status women are more apt to smash
yet it doesn't seem plausible to me that
if you're the head of the imf
old and gray then a maid would be super
down to jump your brittle bones
and then clean 20 hotel rooms offensive
and implausible
when they accuse the union for the hotel
workers of running a prostitution racket
but but i don't think many people could
handle the drudgery of being a maid and
prostitute simultaneously
that's funnier than i can that's really
funny even betray because i'm focusing
on my
reading so even if he was set up i don't
feel bad for him because he should have
spotted the whole scenario as being mad
fishy
although am i ignorant do you think that
it is plausible
that it is a plausible scenario in his
world and not
and i'm not even talking about the hey
let's have drink and hang out
and if everything is cool things will
progress from there i'm talking
specifically
hi my name is and we're [ __ ]
especially if you're way more rich than
famous
did you think she was a big fan of his
views on third world debt relief
sakura blue it's ridiculous that's the
guy had two good jokes
which i'm too
zapped to laugh at the one about his
views on the imf
what do you think uh i think he's it's a
great point
um and thinking that
it actually brings up the my notion that
women
women love hotel rooms women gets
freakier in hotel rooms because you
don't have to do any of the work
this is the opposite of that okay women
women sexually women it's like it
doesn't it's like a [ __ ]
gray zone it's like a gray zone where
whatever you do in a hotel
as a woman does not count against your
record
so women it's on no holds barred
um and so thinking that you can
have sex with a cleaning lady
is pretty wild and also thinking
when you're done here you'll clean eight
rooms is
doubly wild and uh so it makes
whose side am i on i think he'd
absolutely i mean
if you got to the end it's unequivocally
like the guy's a
[ __ ] dirt bag um
what do you think bianca yeah i don't
think i also think that
especially in the when you work very
closely with each other
everyone knows you're dirt i know
everybody i've ever worked with i know
if someone does something shady
i don't always know exactly what they're
doing
but i don't think you know my dirt i
don't necessarily know your dirt but i
don't you don't
in our work relationship you don't do
your dirt around me
yeah whereas let's say if i've worked in
a
like you know yeah in like working just
places
30 40 hours a week and people are
drinking and all that yeah like any time
i've worked
side by side with someone that's why
this is a dry work environment
because i can't trust no so i don't know
you're dirt but
if yeah it's it's like if like if i'm
i know which i know certain people that
do certain things
i wouldn't do yeah and i know like you
just know
and also a hotel that you work at it's a
horrible place to do dirt sorry
yeah no 100 and you people know when
you're missing
people know when you're like not there
but i could
go a whole shift and not talk to
somebody but the moment i take
15 minutes to just get the [ __ ] away
from people
where were you we were looking for you
like there's it's really but that's all
when you go on break
and you're like just there's no mine or
whatever you take 15 minutes to like
go out back or whatever that's when you
catch people doing [ __ ]
there's too much like you know
i feel like at a hotel let's just say
this lady was
someone would have known something
someone has seen something hotels are
always being monitored
so just ignore let's just pretend you
didn't watch the documentary
i find it really weird that you would
and also if you're
[ __ ] like and then there was like
they implied oh well she knew it was the
head of the imf
how many people do you think stay there
she loves his take on of that yeah
exactly
so how many people do you think say
there that's a joke of mine
yeah no i do that in my act i have a
question about joke stealing
yep um so a friend of mine who's like
just a
open micro had been doing a joke for a
while
and then a uh like a
made guy yeah made like a like a
headliner
sorry doing it so the the open micro
hit him up and was like hey i've been
doing
almost that exact same joke for a year
that's what we call tough titty and then
the other guy was like
cool okay could you stop doing it no
yeah that's one of those things like
cool so
this is prison literally and he was like
that's [ __ ] up
i don't know if i've never met you no it
wasn't he wasn't implying
he's right oh well then it was just like
why would i why would i let
you do it i was because the
other guy had been doing it way longer
and it was prove like it was very much
like the headliner it was
his new material yeah and the other guy
had been doing it for like let's just
say maybe max a year and a half
and he was like well i've been doing it
for a while he's like cool could you
stop
yeah in a way and the guy stopped
but he felt really up he was ready he's
gonna be paid for that by the
headliner's fund
who pays off open micros who yeah that's
just one of those
things yeah i've had that happen and
it's not i couldn't
what do you say there's nothing you can
say
it's just one it's a tough one it's
gonna
look like i i've seen guys do
people's i've seen i've seen guys do
netflix specials
and then i'll see somebody else
doing the same joke like two years later
and i used to tell them and now i don't
even bother
because it's like it's not they don't i
don't think they stole it
no i just it's just one of them things
that you just you're going to look
stupid but i don't know
i'm not going to ruin what do you want
to look stupid or you want to have me
ruin four days of your life
because he's going to be in a dip right
he's going to go
he's going to do it it's going to be a
dip stick
he's going to be in dip dip
dip stick he's going to be in a dip
so there's nothing you can do i do i i'm
reminded of a story of a guy this is
back to the
cleaning lady thing it's so hard not to
say made i
know we have it's very hard it's so much
better to call them a cleaning lady
um and uh
in montreal comedian and
his wife i'm sorry his the cleaning lady
he was just a single
fat not attractive guy [ __ ] him
and he could he was like in tears
why because it was that never happens
like it never happened yeah it sounds
like a point now yeah like and he
couldn't believe that something like
that had happened to him
and he was so grateful i remember
letterman telling that story about when
drew
barrymore flashed him and he was like i
was just so grateful
because my whole life i'd i'd hear god
stories of guys being like
yeah i was on the way here and some lady
pulled me over and [ __ ] me
right and then when it finally happens
bianca so what i'm saying is
make some man's year guys are
so weird give him some unsolicited
remember i told you i
my weird roommate that uh hadn't had
been with a
woman who's a virgin he was the incel
that ended up becoming a
trans woman anyways uh
for a while leading up to that we didn't
know that that happened
years after i didn't live with her but
at the time
uh she was a man and she was just a
virgin
like a nor a dirt like a nerd and
every guy i told like oh my roommate's a
little weird
like give him some just break him off
come on it's so weird that guys think
it it cost you nothing to help him
yeah i'm with him that's so good i gotta
just lube yourself up
ew we don't have that we have to
we need psyche no you guys can [ __ ]
anything
right but i'm saying we can't get a
boner for anything
we can't i can't work spray my dick hard
yeah but you can make it work
because it you get not at this age
no i mean you can make it work but yeah
i don't know it's different when for us
bianca another classic in the books a
[ __ ]
classic um thank you all for listening
and looking
thanks for listening thanks for
listening
and um
i hope that we helped or didn't hurt
can you say something nice because this
is monday and
wednesday is the inauguration i mean
say a good word corn pop save us
i if corn pop is there on wednesday yo
if corn pop was
papa's there is
just put corn pop on the at sitting at
the foot
at the foot of the podium try some even
if he's old it's 80 probably at this
point
would would you do it would you just do
it zoom if you were biden at this point
i don't th this is where it makes me
this is where government
makes me a little insane where it's like
just go
inside just yeah why does that
we let terrorists we let 11 terrorists
ruin flying so we can
do other [ __ ] like we don't have to
like if we change one bit we it was
as any as if anyone was taking strength
from
you know we i'm from america and we do
outdoor changes of power
so so you know unless it rains
unless it rains then we change it up a
little bit but uh
i do you think we're in a time of
someone might get assassinated because
that hasn't happened for a while
i mean you know obviously they're
they're all
you know the the national guard or
whomever is protecting just one of them
has to be a white supremacist and
anything one queuing out of twenty five
thousand we can't
we literally said we can't make sure
it's 100 secure then go inside
yeah go inside i don't
know yeah why are we when i bought a
rolex we didn't do it outside
it's like when you're doing [ __ ] you'd
go to a place where it's safe
that's all i'm saying goodbye
you've got mail
[Music]